Da bin ich eine Woche auf dem Bauernhof quasi.
Nice.
Ja, Kuppel machte hier Hippie-Woche.
Da heißt es immer, wir haben irgendwie ein Haus irgendwo im Dorf, das so von so ein paar Bauernhüften umgeben ist.
Und da sind immer ganz viele Leute dann so aus seinem Schul-Uniformeskreis eingeladen.
Das ist witzig.
Und dann, keine Ahnung, sitzt er halt so zehnt an der Tafel draußen im Freien und isst gemeinsam.
Er bäckst dir selber Brot und machst selber Nudeln und fängst dir Fische nebenan.
Er macht selber Käse aus Rohmilch von irgendwelchen Bauernhöfen um die Ecke.
Das ist ganz kurz, ich bin kein Mensch mit dem Übercomputer.
Aber wo wir gerade noch dabei sind, wenn wir über Computer reden.
Herr Hendrik.
Hey Köln.
Schön, dass wir uns mal wieder zusammensetzen.
Du hast schon länger keine Folge mehr aufgenommen.
Wie lange ist denn die letzte Folge her?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ist denn wahrscheinlich ein Monat oder so?
Ach ja, genau.
Das war, als ich mit Jupp durch dieses übelste Gewitter gefahren bin.
Wir klatschnass hier saßen.
Hier stand Joops Fahrrad und er saß
in Unterhose hier am Tisch.
Folge namens nackt.
Es hatte übrigens den Side-Effekt, dass meine Schuhe,
ich habe ja hier solche
Stoff-Sneaker, die waren
derartig durchgeweicht, dass die
zwei Tage lang nass waren und wenn die nass sind,
dann werden die so morsch.
Und mir sind, nachdem ich dann
neulich nochmal in den Regen gekommen bin
und die Schuhe nochmal einen Tag nass waren,
sind mir beim
Binden der Schnürsenkel die Schnürsenkel zerrissen.
Scheiße. Beide. Beide?
Aber es gibt ja nur einen, also beide Seiten vom gleichen.
Am linken Schuh und am rechts.
Ach so, Mann, du bist bei der Schuh.
Oh Gott, scheiße.
Das heißt, ich bin in den Schuhladen rein
und habe mir erstmal neue Schnürsenkel gekauft und habe überlegt,
wie lange können Schnürsenkel sein?
Da kriegst du 75 cm
und 90 cm
und 120 cm
und 180 cm.
Zwei Meter Schnürsenkel?
Und ich habe mir gedacht, das kann ja auch nicht.
Also ich kaufe mir mal,
was mache ich?
90 cm Schnürsenkel wären ja wohl reichen.
Ich wüsste nicht, woran ich das festmache.
An deinen Schuhen.
Ja.
Und zumindest gehe ich
damit nach Hause. Ich hatte die Schuhe nicht mit,
weil ich mit Sandalen rumgelaufen bin.
Zu Hause setze ich mich dann hin
und mache die Schnürsenkel raus und will die neuen reinmachen
und merke, dass es hinten und vorne nicht reicht,
weil 90 cm viel zu kurz sind.
Dann bin ich am nächsten Tag nochmal hin und habe mir 120 cm Schnürsenkel
reingekommen. Also diese Schuhe, die ich jetzt hier anhabe,
Da sind 1,20 Meter
Schnürsenkel drin.
Mach ruhig ein Foto für die Show Notes.
Das Foto müsste jetzt
gerade das Cover Art
von dem Podcast sein.
Wenn du das hinkriegst, du willst ja diese Folge
mit Garageband geschnitten haben.
Ja, das macht ja auch vorne.
Das solltet ihr hinkommen. Und wenn ihr das nicht sehen könnt
in eurem Client, wenn ihr das nicht kann,
dann habt ihr auch nichts verpasst.
Das ist eigentlich so schlimm.
Ja, was ist denn alles passiert seitdem?
in der Welt
ein paar Sachen, aber
keine Ahnung, auf was wir jetzt eingehen wollen.
Ich muss sagen, ich bekomme von der Welt auch gar nicht mehr so viel mit, wenn ich irgendwie nach Hause komme.
Ich gucke nur noch
irgendwie mal eine Stunde YouTube, bevor ich ins Bett gehe.
Dann bekomme ich gar keine wirklichen Nachrichten mehr mit.
Nee, Quatsch, das stimmt nicht. Ich höre den ganzen Tag Radio.
Aber ich gucke dann tonnenweise
sowas wie Late Show mit
Stephen Colbert abends.
Da kriege ich eigentlich nur noch den Verkehrsunfall von nebenan mit.
Sonst ist ja
Last Week Tonight auch gerade wieder
Hiatus und macht Pause.
Leider. Schade, ne?
Dafür ist es bei uns weitergegangen.
Ja, aber bitte erzähl mir nicht mehr drüber.
Ich bin einer von denjenigen, die
die ersten 5, 6, 7, 8 Folgen
abwarten, fast die gesamte Staffel und es dann
binge-watchen. Ich sagte nur, es geht gut weiter.
Es macht jetzt schon Spaß. Also richtig
Spaß. Ja, das denke ich mir auch, aber ich möchte
nicht nach einer Folge eine Woche warten müssen, bis
die nächste gucken kann. Wenn wir schon bei
Serien sind, Rick and Morty ist immer noch nicht weitergegangen,
oder? Scheiße, ne? Die Schweine
verarschen eine richtig...
April war das.
Wir haben ja fast August jetzt.
Krass, ey.
Vielleicht machen die gar keine weiteren Folgen.
Vielleicht haben die echt nur noch diese eine gemacht.
Direkt nach der...
Das bin ich traurig.
Weiß ich nicht. Das ist bloß eine Vermutung.
Nö, das wäre blöd.
Ich hoffe.
Aber sonst neben Serien ist natürlich auch
viel anderes passiert bestimmt.
Aber was gibt es denn so ansonsten für coole neue Serien?
Ich bin irgendwie raus, was sowas angeht.
Apropos...
Silicon Valley muss ich nochmal weitergucken.
Apropos Serien, das ist witzig, dass du das erwähnst,
weil da wollte ich tatsächlich noch was ansprechen.
Ich habe vergessen, das mit in den Pett zu schmeißen.
Die Game of Thrones-Macher,
das soll ja jetzt die letzte Staffel GOT sein,
soweit ich verstanden habe.
Aber ich habe aus unterschiedlichen Fällen auch gehört,
dass es doch noch bis zur 9. weitergeht.
Wir sind jetzt bei der 7.
Soll die jetzt überhaupt 10 Folgen haben?
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
Auf jeden Fall habe ich jetzt vor ein paar Tagen gelesen,
dass die beiden Showrunner
eine neue Serie namens Confederate planen,
die quasi so ein bisschen von der Idee her ist
wie Man in the High Castle,
so Alternate Universe.
Aber die Konföderation
hat ein Civil War gewonnen.
Genau, die Südstadt haben gewonnen.
Die Idee ist so witzig, die Klingmarkt,
ist halt so, ich finde das so
unglaublich deplatziert und dumm,
Amerika jetzt eine Serie zu geben, wo sich
die White Power Spacken so richtig
einen auf Starerei runterholen können.
Das ist so eine unglaublich bescheuerte
Idee. Ja, ich muss noch sagen, ich bin von ein paar
anderen Serien, die so gehabt wurden,
gar nicht so geflasht gewesen. Also,
The Man in the High Castle. Das war komisch. Die ersten
Folgen geschaut, die überhaupt nicht hängt.
Das ging irgendwie nicht los.
Und selbst Westworld
fand ich jetzt...
Also, diese letzte Folge,
Spoiler Alert,
ist mir egal, ihr hört das jetzt.
Die ist ja jetzt ein paar Monate alt.
In der letzten Folge,
oder meinetwegen springt,
ihr habt jetzt noch 5 Sekunden, um zu dem nächsten Chapter Mark
zu sprengen. 5,
4, 3,
zumindest in der letzten Folge
kriegt man dann so mit, dass diese ganzen Plotlines,
die man die ganze Staffel lang nebenbei gesehen hat
und sich gedacht hat, hä, was passiert
denn hier, ist ein bisschen durcheinander,
seltsam, warum sehen sich
die Leute untereinander nie, dass
quasi dieser alte Typ und der junge Typ
der gleiche Typ sind,
bloß irgendwie 30 Jahre auseinander
und man merkt das nicht, weil die
Roboter, mit denen die interagieren, halt nicht altern
und dann denkst du dir so, okay, warte mal,
super, darf ich mir jetzt die gesamte Staffel
nochmal angucken unter diesem Gesichtspunkt?
Also sie hatten es vorher so ein bisschen mal immer,
ich will nicht sagen angedeutet,
aber man konnte es ahnen. Und das war so eine Theorie
auch, ich weiß nicht mehr, ob ich das
mir gedacht hatte oder ob ich das zufällig im
Subredd irgendwo gelesen hatte. Die Theorie
lebte auf jeden Fall schon und Leute haben es
unter diesem Gesichtspunkt schon geschaut,
auf jeden Fall, bevor die letzten zwei, drei Folgen raus waren.
Aber ich fand das cool, dass es auf jeden Fall
so bestätigt hatte und sich so geäußert hatte.
Aber Westworld war von der Prämisse her
unglaublich cool. Ja, es war auch
ganz nett anzusehen. Das Setting fand ich einfach nur geil.
das hat Spaß gemacht, ich liebe solche
aber die haben auch zum Schluss die gesamten Hauptcharaktere
quasi abgesäbelt und
fangen jetzt quasi bei
Null an in der nächsten Staffel
und sie haben auch überlegt, dass da neben Westworld
gibt es auch noch, keine Ahnung, Eastworld
oder Spaceworld
Eastworld spielt in Sowjetrussia oder was?
Keine Ahnung, also zumindest ist Westworld
wohl nur einer von mehreren
Theme-Parks
und so war das
in dem Film zum Beispiel schon
das basierte auf einem Film aus den 70ern
ältere Filme.
Und ja, also quasi
ist die nächste Staffel jetzt eine
komplett neue Serie.
Also einfach alles... Aber ein paar Sachen
haben sie ja noch offen gelassen. Ich meine, das ist in Ordnung.
Ich finde es auch nicht schlimm, wenn so eine Serie,
wenn es da bloß eine Staffel gibt, weil es ist im Prinzip komplexer
Film. Ja. Bei manchen
Serien fand ich es schade, also Firefly hat es so ruhig
weitergebracht. Ja, aber das war ja keine Absicht.
Also das Dumme daran war ja,
dass die die erste Staffel
produziert haben und Fox hat die
ausgestrahlt. Aber keiner hat
Fox gesagt, dass das halt
vor der Serie ist, wo die Folgen aufeinander
aufbauen. Fox hat die halt random gezeigt
und Nutzer, äh,
Zuschauer hat das halt nicht verstanden.
Da haben sie wieder abgesetzt, weil die Eichhörigen mies waren.
Achso, was ich jetzt mal geguckt habe,
ist auch schon wieder ein paar Jahre alt,
die Serie, ist Agent Carter.
Das ist ja gar nichts.
Du kennst vielleicht Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
Ja. Kennst du Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.?
Kenn ich, aber hab ich nie gesehen.
Agents of S.H.I.E.
Die Plotline von Agent Coulson,
der Typ, der in einem
Avengers-Film stirbt.
Ich habe die Avenger-Filme gesehen, aber
der Typ von Shields, der immer mal
kurz kommt und sagt, hi, ich bin von Shields.
Ach, der, der. Ich glaube, ich weiß, was ich meine.
Den haben sie in dem einen Avengers-Film,
ist der von Lucia, irgendwie so aufgespießt worden
und dann haut hier
Samuel L. Jackson
seine Football-Sammelkarten
oder seine Baseball-Sammelkarten auf den Tisch.
Er hat gesagt, er hat an eure Helden geglaubt
und jetzt kraft euch mal zusammen.
und der Tod von dem war so das Schlüsselerlebnis,
warum die Avengers sich dann doch nicht mehr
gestritten haben und da gibt es irgendwie
die Plot-Twist, er war nicht
wirklich tot und dann gab es irgendwie eine Serie, die
ging über vier Staffeln, die war gar nicht mehr so schlecht, die haben
zwar die ganzen Avengers-Charaktere
immer mal bloß so namentlich erwähnt
und nie gezeigt, aber
so als Serie selber war das gar nicht mehr so schlecht,
wenn du ein bisschen auf so dummen Action-Sci-Fi
zu Spaß stehst. Und dann
gab es halt noch eine zweite Serie, die hieß
Agent Carter und es gab in diesen ganzen
Captain America und
auch bei Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
gab es immer mal Rückblenden, so in die
40er, als
Steven Rogers kommt ja aus den 40er Jahren,
als er so ein Zweiter Weltkriegsheld
und da gab es
eine Mitarbeiterin von
SSR,
Scientific Strategic Reserve,
so eine
Vorinstitution vor S.H.I.E.L.D.
Und die hat quasi S.H.I.E.L.D.
gegründet
und die Serie
Agent Carter spielt in den 40ern
und erzählt so die Geschichte von ihr und es ging so
voran. Sollte eigentlich bis zu dem Punkt gehen, wo sie dann irgendwann
mal SHIELD gründet, aber ist leider auch
nach zwei Staffeln abgesetzt worden.
Da war aber das witzige, die hatte ein Sidekick,
das war der Butler
von
Tony Starks Vater.
Hieß auch Stark, ich hab den Vornamen
vergessen. Und der Butler hieß Jarvis.
Schön.
Das ist dann unterwegs gewesen mit Mr. Jarvis.
Das war eigentlich auch eine ganz witzige Serie.
Mir gehen auch ein bisschen die Sci-Fi-Serien aus. Als nächstes muss ich nochmal die Expanse von vorne gucken.
Kuppe hat mir jetzt die Bücher empfohlen.
Echt, da gibt es Bücher zu? Okay, sind hoffentlich ein bisschen besser.
Man merkt, die haben Geld, aber ich fand die Story ein bisschen lacking.
Also so eine schöne Nebenher-Serie und keine krass-Serie.
Aber Hut ab für eine Serie, die tatsächlich Smartphones in der Plotline verwendet.
Es gibt ja genügend Serien
und Filme, wo
Internet und Smartphones
überhaupt nicht in der Star-Ray vorkommen,
weil es irgendwie zu abgefahren ist,
damit Plotlines zu erklären. Es gibt ja auch viele
Filme, die sinnloserweise
in den 90ern und in den 80ern plötzlich spielen,
weil die Handlung in der
Gegenwart von Smartphones
überhaupt keinen Sinn ergeben würde.
Muss man drauf achten. Es gibt ein paar Filme, wo ich denke,
warum spielt das jetzt plötzlich in den 80ern?
Stimmt, wir müssen das Ding mal hinterfragen.
Interessant, habe ich nie drüber nachgedacht.
Und bei The Expanse spielen zumindest Smartphones eine mittelwichtige Rolle.
Da haben sie zumindest Mühe gegeben, sich darüber nachzudenken,
wie die in 100 Jahren aussehen.
Das ist interessant.
Aropos gute Sci-Fi-Selien, was ich mir jetzt mal aufgenommen habe,
wieder mal zu schauen, ist Babylon 5.
Tolle Serie.
Ich liebe Babylon 5.
Die Story ist einfach nur großartig.
Die Animationen sind einfach nur witzig.
Das ist halt alt.
Das ist ja der 90er.
Ich meine, die sind nicht so, dass sie es super lustig machen.
die geht halt einfach so hin und dann ist es halt so.
Aber die Story-Arc über die fünf Staffeln hinweg,
oder die ersten vier, glaube ich, die fünfte ist ein bisschen komisch.
Die ist ein bisschen angehängt, aber...
Die Story-Arc, die einfach komplett aufziehen,
großartig. Also wer es noch nicht gesehen hat,
wir haben es zur Empfehlung.
Aber wo wir gerade mal dabei sind,
was auch geil ist und leider viel zu früh aufgehört hat,
ist Farscape.
Das habe ich auch nie gesehen. Farscape musste man kommen.
Wollen wir mal schauen.
Die haben auch ein paar Storytelling-mäßig
krasse Sachen gemacht. So mal eben
den Hauptcharakter verdoppelt und dann die
abwechselnd mal hier und mal dort mit dem gleichen
Charakter spielen lassen.
Ohne zu viel vorauszunehmen.
Interessant.
Gut. Farscape.
Okay, ist auf meiner
Watchliste.
Gut, schauen wir uns unsere Themen an.
Wir haben erstmal noch ein Stück
ganz kurzes Follow-up zu einer
der letzten Folgen, wo ich es mal erwähnt hatte,
wo ich nicht geblickt habe, was
genau eigentlich
Ethereum ausmacht. Da habe ich jetzt
vor ein paar Tagen die witzige Seite entdeckt
whatthefuckisetherium.com. Kannst du es mir jetzt
erklären?
Meine
Vermutung damals ist prinzipiell
genau das. Also du hast
diese Arbitrary Code
Smart Contract, die du in die Blockchain mit reinhängst
und die von allen ausgeführt werden.
Aber was ist das, was halt immer wieder auf Hacker News auch kommt,
sind Leute haben halt Bugs drin und
beziehungsweise dieser Ethereum, ich will jetzt nicht
sagen, kommt. Du hast quasi nicht nur
Transaktionen so von
Key, also von
ID, einen Value nach
anderer ID, sondern du hast auch noch
irgendwie so Code-Snippets in der
Mitdrage. Da können halt ganze Programme drin hängen
und die machen halt, was du möchtest.
Und das muss jeder, der das evaluiert, immer wieder
ausführen? Insofern ich
das jetzt verstanden habe, werden die dann
von allen immer ausgeführt, ja. Das klingt
nach einer großartigen Idee.
Das Witzige ist halt, dass dieser
in Anführungsstrichen mal Ethereum Compiler
oder Ethereum Script Compiler oder was
immer das ist, worin du das dann schreibst,
ein paar witzige Optimizations hat,
wo sie tatsächlich wirklich
machen und Dinge rausfallen lassen.
Und ich will nicht sagen, dass das dazu führt, aber
unter anderem sicher, beziehungsweise
einfach ein Verpackten-Code, den Leute schreiben,
führt in letzter Zeit immer wieder dazu, dass einer der
Top-Hosts of Hacker-News jeden zweiten Tag
gefühlt zu sein scheint, dass hier und da
Millionen an Ether verloren gegangen sind
oder weggeflossen sind oder sonst was.
Super.
Was für eine andere Seite ist, man kann auch ansagen,
hier, explain it like I'm an average person,
just trying to get by, oder
I'm a total nerd, I'm five, I like videos,
I like podcasts.
Du hast da halt ein paar Videos, die das erklären.
Geh mal auf das IM5, das war glaube ich jetzt witzig.
Also IM5.
Don't say fuck.
So schön.
Ethereum is a way for a bunch of computers to talk to each other.
People can ask these computers to run programs that can't easily be shut down
because all the computers share the code with each other.
Das ist halt sehr abstrakt jetzt, aber ja.
Was ich spannend fand in dem Zusammenhang,
ich habe mich ja wirklich auch nicht viel mit
unterschiedlichen digitalen Währungen
auseinandergesetzt, aber es gibt eine schöne Folge
von Radiolab über Zcash.
Und was für einen Aufwand die betrieben haben.
was für einen Aufwand die betrieben haben, um diese
Währung loszutreten.
Weil du musstest irgendwie am Anfang ein
verteiltes Shared Secret schaffen.
Quasi einen Key erzeugen,
ohne dass jemand wirklich selber den Private Key
hat. Und wie sie das
machen, wird in dieser Radio Lab-Folge
recht gut beschrieben.
Die haben ja da so einen
witzigen Zwischenfall, ohne jetzt
das zu spoilern. Bei Zcash? Achso,
in der Folge, aber da sind die nicht nochmal
drauf eingegangen, was da eigentlich genau ist. Das wissen sie auch nicht, oder?
Nicht wirklich, nee.
weiß nicht, ob sie das nicht vor Ort gemacht haben,
um die Folge ein bisschen spannender zu machen. Kann sein, aber das
klang schon arg
hart.
Da nehme ich das sehr, sehr ernst, da jetzt einen Angriff
reinzuschieben. Aber das ist eine coole Folge.
Also warte mal, wir haben jetzt
Bitcoin, wir haben Ethereum,
wir haben Zcash und wir haben so ein paar
Bitcoin-Forks, sowas wie
Dogecoin. Das ist ja kein Bitcoin-Fork.
Wir haben zigtausend andere Kryptowährungen.
Aber das, ich meine,
ich meine, das sind sowas wie
Dogecoin ist die identische Software
wie Bitcoin.
Ähnlich. Die nutzen einen anderen
Hashing-Algorithmus und das macht sie halt aus.
Ja, die haben halt andere
Parameter gewählt, aber
im Endeffekt, das ist...
Nicht nur andere Parameter, ich würde schon sagen, die erscheinen sich ein bisschen mehr.
Viele von den Kryptowährungen sind tatsächlich
per Hand neu geschrieben,
anders implementiert, weil Leute
das tatsächlich einfach... Die Grundidee von Bitcoin
ist ja recht simpel, mit der Blockchain und
alle rechnen halt, um die
zu hashen, die Transaktionen zusammenschieben
das in den Blockchain eintragen und dann kriegt es dafür
einen Reward. Das ist ja das Grundprinzip.
Genau, aber so allgemein,
ich meine, ich finde es cool, dass es so ganz
viele evolutionäre Projekte
gibt quasi, die was Neues ausprobieren und dann
wieder weggehen und sterben oder erfolgreich sind oder auch nicht.
Aber was zeichnet sich denn momentan
so ab, was das angeht? Also Bitcoin ist
jetzt auch irgendwie so ein bisschen out, weil es viel zu
teuer geworden ist. Deswegen gibt es ja jetzt
übermorgen zum Zeitpunkt dieser Aufnahme
am 1. August einen harten Bitcoin
Fork in Bitcoin Cash und
klassisch Bitcoin. Was genau es
damit auf sich hat, muss sich jetzt ein bisschen passen.
Ich meine, die gehen viele Probleme an, was
die Größe der einzelnen Blöcke angeht.
Das würden sie doppelt so groß machen.
Und andere Sachen, vor allem
Transaktionskosten, die gerade viel zu hoch stellen.
Das heißt, es gibt dann zwei Blockchains?
Es gibt dann zu dem Zeitpunkt zwei Blockchains und
das Netzwerk muss sich entscheiden, was passiert.
Okay. Und womit
weitergehen. Auf welcher Blockchain
meinen dann die großen
chinesischen
Miningen?
Die haben halt die Macht, das zu entscheiden, was dann
überlebt von den beiden Projekten. Achso,
das ist gar nicht, wir machen jetzt eins für
den Use Case, dass sich der eine damit Burger kauft
und der andere ist für die großen Schwarzgeldmärkte.
Das wäre quasi eine neue Kryptowährung, die du dann schaffen müsstest.
Okay, das heißt, okay,
davon soll wirklich bloß eine übrig bleiben.
Soweit ich das verstanden habe, ja.
Okay, also ihr seid jetzt wahrscheinlich
schlauer als wir, weil wir es bestimmt nicht schaffen werden,
bis übermorgen diese Folge rauszubringen.
In der nächsten Folge reden wir mal
ein bisschen mehr drüber, da werden wir uns mal ein bisschen,
Ich werde mich auf jeden Fall einlesen, weil ich das hochspannend finde.
Du machst mir Versprechungen.
Ich meine, ich kriege jetzt fast
von diversen Seiten,
wo ich noch Accounts habe, wie Kraken.com
oder Coinbase.com, die halt so
Hosted Wallets sind oder Marketplaces für
Kryptowährungen, die mir jetzt entweder
schreiben, hier, wir führen das jetzt bei uns ein oder nein,
wir unterstützen das nicht und wir schauen mal,
was passiert.
Ich habe übrigens auf dem Telefon, mit dem wir
gerade aufnehmen, auch noch so 2 Euro in Bitcoin.
Kann ich dir die irgendwie, kannst du mir die auszahlen?
Du kannst die mir einfach schicken, dann nutze ich die
als Bitcoin und ich gebe dir 2 Euro dafür.
Das war meine Überlegung.
Oder ist die Transaktionsgebühr mittlerweile so hoch?
Die ist bei knapp unter 2 Euro aktuell.
Ach du Scheiße.
Also kannst du mal schauen, was passiert.
Also habe ich quasi, das ist quasi
totes Geld, was ich da habe.
Fast, ja.
Apropos totes Geld, ich war ja neulich
eine Woche zum Spaß,
ein kompletter Themenwechsel, ich war eine Woche zum Spaß
in London.
Zum Spaß, okay.
Es nennt sich Urlaub.
und
ich habe dummerweise, ich habe
ein bisschen Geld geweckt, die haben da irgendwie offenbar
so eine ganz andere Währung. Komisch, ich dachte,
die sind in der EU.
Wir haben wahrscheinlich irgendwann gecheckt,
dass sie vergessen haben, ihr Geld um alle umzutauschen
in Euro und deswegen
sagen sie, tauschen wir jetzt alles um, nee, ist ein bisschen
aufwendiger, gehen wir halt wieder raus aus der EU.
Das wird sein.
Und ich bin zurückgekommen
und habe festgestellt, dass ich noch 60 Pfund in der
Portemonnaie habe und denke ich mir,
was mache ich damit, behalte ich das, vielleicht gehe ich irgendwann mal
wieder hin oder tausche ich das hier
irgendwo um, da haben ja aber Leute gesagt, das kostet ein Schweinegeld
das hier oben zu tauschen, dann mache ich voll los
auf der anderen Seite habe ich irgendwie Schiss, dass diese
60 Pfund
du meinst nach dem EU-Austritt nichts mehr wert sind
oder was? Demnächst nichts mehr wert sind
also momentan sind es ungerechnet zu 80, 90 Euro
schon nicht wenig
also nicht nichts
naja, es reicht
gerade so um zwei Wochen damit
mit der Tube durch die Stadt zu fahren
beziehungsweise es reicht gerade so um
in London einmal gut Mittagessen zu gehen.
Ich habe mich mit einem Kumpel getroffen.
Vlad,
den kenne ich hier von diversen
Rustfesten und
Chaos Communication Kongressen.
Der arbeitet als
Softwareentwickler in London.
Wir waren essen in so einem
recht netten, also nicht übelst
schicken, aber ganz netten türkischen Restaurant da.
So ein paar bisschen wie Tabas gegessen.
Er hat zwei Cocktails getrunken, ich habe zwei Bier
getrunken.
Witzigerweise Effes, das Bier, was
hier in jedem Dönerladen kriegst.
Stark.
Und wie gesagt,
wir haben jetzt nicht übertrieben
und kriegen zum Schluss die Rechnung und ich denke so,
haben wir zu zweit
für 100 Pfund gegessen.
Ich habe mir dann gedacht,
naja gut, okay,
meine Unterkunft hier in London,
ich habe bei einer Freundin übernachtet,
ist quasi für laut, dann mache ich jetzt mal hier
gute Mähne zum bösen Spiel und du so, als wäre das
nichts für mich.
Und dann war ich aber
letztes Wochenende mit
zwei Freunden mal eben auf einer
Fahrradtour unterwegs und bin
mit denen nach Usti gefahren, also hier von
Dresden raus, sind das nur
94 Kilometer mit dem Fahrrad und Elberadweg lang
bis dem Usti.
Da sind wir da
in so eine Brauerei gegangen
und haben da zu dritt
gegessen
für 28 Euro.
Das ist krass.
Also was ein Unterstand ist einfach so interessant.
Das ist super krass.
Die einen zu zweit umgerechnet für 120
und die anderen, es war nicht
in Usti zu dritt, das waren nicht 28 Euro.
Ich habe die Biere bezahlt.
Das kommt noch drauf.
Also waren es vielleicht
38 Euro zu dritt.
Das ist ein gigantischer Unterschied.
Das ist ein krasser Unterschied.
Das ist ein Drittel.
Oh Mann.
Aber sonst kann ich London eigentlich empfehlen.
Ich bin da so ein bisschen rumgelatscht.
Das ist eine schöne Stadt.
Ich bin halt viel mit der Typ gefahren, das funktioniert auch super.
Die Oesterkarte ist so praktisch.
Ja, die Oesterkarte ist super. Ich bin da am Flughafen
Heathrow angekommen, hab mir die gekauft,
50 Pfund drauf geladen
und da bin ich eigentlich jeden Tag damit irgendwie durch die Stadt gefahren.
Ist auch super, weil du gehst irgendwo
runter, dann kommt da innerhalb von drei Minuten
kommt halt der nächste Typ, dann steigst du da ein.
Die sind alle ein bisschen eng,
wenn du hier in Dresden-Straßenbahn fährst, die sind wesentlich
geräumiger als so eine Typ. Die sind auch
rund, also das heißt am Rand kommt da die Wände
auf dich zu, die sind halt oben,
das ist wirklich rund.
Und dann fährst du damit durch die Gegend und halt am Ende
dieser Woche, die ich da war,
habe ich echt 50 Pfund verfahren gehabt.
Also als ich in Heathrow auf dem Rückweg
wieder ausgecheckt habe,
das kriegst du ja immer angezeigt, wenn du da durch so eine
Drehtür gehst, wie viel du noch drauf hast, da hatte ich da
irgendwie minus 70 Penny
drauf oder sowas.
70 Erdbeerbauchpenny.
Stark. Auch das geht weg.
Ja, das ist ratzfatz.
Also in London, wenn du da wohnst, musst du schon
eine ganze Menge Geld verdienen, damit das geht.
Was mich interessant fand,
Ich bin vor nicht einfach einer Zeit bei London weiß, dass gerade hier an jeder Tür gefühlten Security-Typ steht.
Und in jedem Bus, an jedem Eingang, außer vorne, wo der Fahrer sitzt, ist auch ein Security.
Es geht momentan.
Also was mir aufgefallen ist, dass du an vielen öffentlichen Orten, wo du so vom Straßenverkehr in die Fußgängerzonen reingehst,
da hast du solche Stahltore gehabt.
Die sahen so ein bisschen aus wie Schleusen.
Das heißt, du bist durch so eine
Phonebooth-förmige
Säulenschweißstruktur
durchgegangen und unten waren solche großen
nicht Poller, sondern die sahen auch aus
wie so Strömungsleitungen, wie solche
Beine von
so Brücken.
Dass du da halt nicht
mit dem Auto durchfahren kannst.
Oder ganz viele von den Brücken hier
Tower Bridge und die Nachbarbrücken
bin ich immer mal drüber gelatscht,
sind alle abgesperrt gewesen
mit irgendwas, dass du halt mit dem Auto
nicht mehr in die Fußgänger reinfahren kannst,
weil das ja jetzt zweimal passiert ist bereits.
Krass, okay.
Also da ist schon, aber sonst hat man
in der Stadt irgendwie nicht sonderlich angemerkt,
dass da die ganze Zeit Terroralarm herrschte.
Das ist auch gut, dass man das nicht mitkriegt.
Haben auch schöne Parks, ich bin dann
vier in Parks unterwegs gewesen.
Ich bin dann da irgendwie
auf die Wiese gesetzt, so ein paar
Gänse angeguckt und dabei
getappt mitgemacht.
War entspannt.
Kann ich im Urlaub nicht loslassen?
Nee, wenn du das Ding aufmachst und du siehst
oben diesen blauen Punkt,
oben rechts auf GitHub, dann denkst du dir,
und auch draufklicken, ist doch spannend.
Ich muss was machen. Das geht mir auch jedes Mal,
wenn mir jemand anders was zeigt auf GitHub
und der ist dann gerade eingeloggt und hat oben so eine Notification.
Das sieht ja gleich aus bei jedem.
Das ist so richtig,
das triggert so richtig was in mir.
Oh, da ist was los.
Eigentlich ist es bei allen
allen anderen Social Networks, ich mache hier gerade
Airports, Social Networks, das ist ja
eigentlich genau das gleiche, wo mich
das längst nicht mehr so juckt, muss ich sagen.
Ich gucke selten bei jemand anderem
in das Social Network Profil rein.
Hier, zeig dir mal meinen Facebook.
Facebook nutzt ja auch keiner mehr.
Nein, seid nie offen.
Ich habe jetzt meinen
Geflüchtlings-Testwerk, das ist schön.
Ich finde, es gibt so eine Messaging-Möglichkeit.
Also kannst du ja Keybase
drüberlegen.
Gitter.
Gitter ist ja Repro-basierter Chat, aber Keybase
als Person-Chat.
Keybase habe ich aber auch schon
lange nicht mehr so richtig benannt.
Ich habe letztens geschrieben und du hast nie geantwortet.
Also warte mal, wir schreiben uns jetzt über Twitter,
Keybase,
Signal,
Slack,
Jabber manchmal.
Manchmal iMessage noch.
Manchmal iMessage.
Jeden Kontakt, den ich erreichen möchte,
erreiche ich. Und bei dir muss ich jedes Mal
bei 5 Minuten nachdenken, fuck, welche Plattformen müssen wir jetzt eigentlich?
Was ist denn das Sinnvollste?
Wir haben mal neulich hinzugefügt, Riot.iM, also Matrix.
Ja, stimmt.
Das ist,
ja, da gibt es bestimmt noch ein paar, die mir jetzt einfach
Fußgrade nicht einfallen. Ich schreibe das jetzt mal über WeChat.
Hm.
Ein Kumpel hatte neulich eine Idee,
sorry, wenn ich das jetzt herauspuste,
aber es gibt es angeblich eh schon,
dass du, viele Editoren
sind ja auf Web-Technologien basiert,
sowas wie Atom oder sowas.
Das ist eine Elektron-App.
Und bei,
das könnte ein GitHub-Star sein,
aber wahrscheinlich kennen es viele schon.
Ich benutze ja auf Arbeit vornehmlich Visual Studio Code.
Das basiert nicht streng genommen auf Elektron,
aber immerhin auf Chrome.
Klar ist es eine Elektron-App.
Nein, das ist nicht ganz eine Elektron-App.
Das basiert auf Chrome, aber es ist keine Elektron-App.
Deswegen ist es so flink?
Wahrscheinlich ist es einfach so flink.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz müsste man ja da ohne weiteres
auch andere Sachen, die man in Webseiten machen kann,
mal eben einbauen können.
Bei Visual Studio Code gibt es ein cooles Add-on,
das heißt GitLens.
Habe ich dir das mal gezeigt?
Ich glaube schon, ich habe es auch mal ausprobiert.
Zumindest siehst du da bei jedem Code-Block,
und das ist gerade auf Arbeit, das ist wichtig,
siehst bei jedem Code-Block, den du dir anschaust,
oben drüber stehen,
eine Annotation, wer hat das gemacht?
Und das siehst du hier der und der vor drei Monaten.
Und beziehungsweise dieser Blog hat so und so vier Autoren.
Dieser Blog hat einen Autor, dieser Blog hat vier Autoren.
Und dann ist das angepasst worden.
Und wenn du da drauf gehst,
dann siehst du auch noch hier ein Git-Blame
rechts daneben. Das ist super schick,
finde ich. Und ein Kumpel hatte
die Idee, dass man das jetzt verbinden könnte,
weil normalerweise steht ja in einem Git-Log
deine E-Mail-Adresse drin.
Ich bin auch schon teilweise von Leuten,
von denen ich noch nie gehört habe, die in ganz anderen Offices
von unserer Firma arbeiten, dann angeschrieben wurden.
Hier, du hast doch an dem und dem Projekt gemacht,
hilf mir mal das sonst so zu machen.
Ich habe dich im Git-Log gesehen dazu.
Du hast dir einen Mail-to-Link oder was?
Die Idee wäre jetzt, dieses GitLens zu verknüppern
mit Videochat.
Oh Gott.
Dass du quasi auf irgendwas klickst
und dann die drei Leute, die daran geschrieben haben,
direkt zu so einem Videokonferenz-Dings einladen könntest.
Das ist geil.
Das wäre mal so ein Spielzeug.
Ja, sowas kommst du aber auch nur,
wie du in der Klitsche für Videokonferenzen arbeitest.
Wie viel Videokonferenz dir so im Alltag bei euch?
Also morgens beim Stand-Up
machen wir ein bestimmtes Meeting auf, das nebenbei
noch läuft, weil manchmal Leute
remote dazukommen.
Ansonsten habe ich
zwei oder drei feste Meetings die Woche.
Das geht.
Aber manchmal ist irgendwas ad hoc,
wo du dann sagst, hier machen das mal schnell.
Aber das ist gar nicht so häufig.
Aber ihr seid intern auch immer alle erreichbar
darüber?
So funktioniert es leider noch nicht ganz.
Deswegen benutzen wir auch noch Slack.
aber ich weiß gar nicht,
wie weit ich jetzt darüber reden sollte.
Aber ja, du kannst immer
auf
unsere
Domain slash deinen
Benutzername gehen und dann hast du auch was aufgemacht.
Ich hatte neulich ein Meeting mit einem Kollegen,
das habe ich mit dem regelmäßig, so ein Sync-Meeting.
Und da habe ich extra meine
Kamera so eingestellt, dass ich den Fidget Cube
nicht im Bild hatte.
Aber ich dachte, das ist vielleicht unhöflich.
Ich meine, der Typ, das ist so ein
so ein Dandy-Nerd,
der sieht mich sogar ähnlich,
den hätte das wahrscheinlich
nicht gestört, aber ich habe mir gedacht, naja,
tun wir mal so, ich bin super aufmerksam
und konzentriert und ich
habe jetzt den Fidget Cube nicht im Bild.
Letzte Woche hatte ich mit dem
ein Meeting, da hatte der auch einen Fidget Cube.
Der hatte sogar einen schickeren,
meiner ist komplett schwarz und die gibt es auch zweifarbig.
Seiner war schwarz und da waren die Knöpfe
und die ganzen kleinen
Appliances dran, waren rot.
Sieht auch gut aus.
Cool.
So.
Nee, lass mal
Toppings gehen.
Wollen wir mal zu den Toppings übergehen.
Die Toppings, genau. Was haben wir heute? Zucker
und Streusel.
Genau.
Und Rust-Meetup-Feedback.
Rust-Meetup-Feedback, ja. Im Endeffekt wollte ich da bloß
mal kurz sagen, ich
organisiere ja in Dresden regelmäßig dieses
Rust-Meetup.
Seitdem wir auf meetup.com sind, kommen tatsächlich
auch Leute. Ziemlich cool.
Das finde ich ziemlich cool. Also da gibt es irgendwie,
wir nehmen diese RSVP-Funktion
von Meetup immer ein bisschen zu ernst,
weil da RSVP nur irgendwie ganz viele Leute,
so du zum Beispiel. Ich habe extra
das letzte Mal wieder entfernt, dass ich nicht komme.
Kommt dann nicht.
Und das erste Mal, dass wir irgendwie Fremde da hatten,
oder neue Leute, die wir nicht direkt angeworben hatten,
weil die selber bei Meetup
gekommen sind, waren wir in der Slup
und da war halt so eine bunte Mischung
aus Leuten, die schon große
Projekte gemacht haben und Leute, die gesagt haben,
also ich habe bis jetzt bloß Scala gehabt
und ich dachte, ich gucke mir das mal an.
da war ich dann so ein bisschen
in so einer Situation, okay, was mache ich jetzt?
Fange ich jetzt bei 0 an oder gebe ich so ein bisschen
ein Overview und dann habe ich so ein bisschen
einen Vortrag gehalten, quasi so ad hoc.
Und letztes Mal hatten wir gesagt,
reden wir mal über ein konkretes Thema,
Testing und CI.
Und da hatte der Felix eigentlich
ziemlich gut was vorbereitet. Welcher Felix?
Felix Döring.
Ah, cool.
Hi Felix.
Hey.
Und der hatte eigentlich auch ein paar
Beispiele zusammengehackt und
hat er dann halt
das Step by Step ist er so durchgegangen, hat das so gezeigt
und ich habe das ganz wenig
immer mal so ein bisschen Kommentare abgegeben.
Und eigentlich
hat er das vornehmlich gemacht.
Und ich habe dann hinterher das Feedback
von einem anderen Kumpel bekommen.
Das war irgendwie langweilig.
Das hat mich
nicht abgeholt.
Aber
was war denn so das Problem? Das war nicht der
Vortrag von Felix, aber was
wir mal davor gemacht hatten, war,
ich hatte am Anfang erzählt, okay, was so und so ist.
Und es gibt übrigens This Week in Rust.
Und dann habe ich so quasi ein Programm gehabt, wo ich
von oben Top-Level angefangen habe.
Und dann habe ich erst mal so ein bisschen News erzählt.
So, was ist denn so passiert?
Und ich glaube, für so ein
Meetup, für so ein Regiebemessiges, könnte man quasi
auch so ein Podcast-artiges Format machen.
Dass du quasi ein Programm hast, dass du durchgehst.
Sagst erst mal Hi. Dann gehst du so ein bisschen
News durch. Das können ja den Leuten
auch Feedback zu geben. Ich glaube, so werde ich das das nächste Mal
auch machen. Ich meine, es gibt eine Tagesordnung, die man einfach
dass du quasi sagst, guck mal, wir treffen uns
einmal im Monat, das heißt, es gibt jetzt vier neue
Ausgaben von This Week in Rust.
Können wir mal ein bisschen drüber quatschen. Was haltet ihr davon?
Habt ihr das alles verstanden? Könnt ihr mir das erklären?
Weil ich habe das und das nicht verstanden. Was findet ihr
an neuen Features, die vorgestellt wurden? Cool.
Dann witzigerweise sind die Meetups
auch bereits mehrmals.
Also jedes zweite ist genau an dem
Tag, an dem eine neue Rust-Version rauskommt gewesen.
Man könnte immer noch über neue Features reden,
die da drin sind oder so.
Und
wird dann in zwei, drei Wochen sein
oder in drei, vier Wochen sein,
dann werde ich mich ein bisschen fester an
so einer Tagesordnung halten, wo wir teilweise
auch komplett, wenn bloß drei Leute
da waren, haben wir überhaupt kein Programm gemacht.
Da haben wir gesagt,
auf welchem Stand bist du?
Auf welchem Stand bist du? Worauf habt ihr Bock?
Dann lasst uns mal gemeinsam
was hacken und dann haben wir gemeinsam
so einen Peer-to-Peer-Chat-Client.
Das war der Zeit, wo ich mit dabei war,
zumindest mit dem Unternehmen saß.
Genau. Also da musst du immer
ganz ad hoc drauf reagieren, aber wenn du zum Beispiel
10 Leute da hast und 5 davon
kennst du nicht, dann musst du halt irgendwie schauen.
Na klar, das macht natürlich schwierig.
Das ist eine Probe-to-Session wahrscheinlich der sinnvollste
Ansatz. Als ich in London war, habe ich mir auch vorher bei
Meetup mal angeguckt, ob ich da irgendwelche Leute treffe, da war
halt leider gerade irgendwie nichts los in der Woche.
Sonst wäre ich zu irgendwelchen Node
oder Rust Meetups gegangen, aber da war gerade nichts.
Schließlich.
Apropos Rust neue Version.
Ich habe jetzt vor ein paar Tagen gelesen,
dass mit der nächsten oder übernächsten
Version irgendwelche Async-Await-Makros
mit reinlatschen sollen. Das klang
mega cool. Weißt du da mehr zu?
Da überrascht ich mich gerade sogar mit.
Das würde mich begeistern,
wenn sowas in der Richtung...
Also das
Makros glaube ich
nicht. Es gibt RFCs
zu Async-Await-Syntax, aber das
würde erstmal auch voraussetzen, dass sowas wie Promises
Teil der Sprache werden. Achso, das muss ja
klar sein, mit rein in die Frage selbst.
Also ich glaube, das ist...
Es gibt witzigerweise unter
Auf der Doc-Seite gibt es ja das Buch und dann das zweite Buch.
Und dann gibt es The Unstable Book.
Es gibt noch ein drittes Buch?
Es gibt vier Bücher.
Ach, das Unstable-Buch.
Ja, stimmt.
Das gibt es auch so Nommeln kennen noch.
Genau, das Dark Arts of Unsafe Rust.
Und dann gibt es das Unstable-Buch.
Und das ist nicht wirklich ein Buch, weil viele von diesen Seiten hier sind leer.
Aber da sind zumindest...
Also auch von einer Auflistung der Unstable-Features.
Da sind Unstable-Features aufgelistet.
Und dann hast du meistens bloß so einen Link zu dem Tracking-Issue dazu.
dass du mal lesen kannst, was es so alles gibt.
Das ist sinnvoll.
Ich glaube, der Autor von Rocket hat sich gedacht,
gut, ich schaue mir das mal an und brauche so viel
an Stable Features wie möglich in meinen Plugin.
Rocket basiert ja leider noch auf
dem Hyper, was nicht Tokyo-basiert ist.
Genau, das nächste Hyper ist jetzt Tokyo-basiert.
Das ist schon Tokyo-basiert, genau.
Und da überlege ich halt jedes Mal, ob hier vielleicht
Request, also diese
REST Client Library,
die so ein bisschen ein einfacheres Interface ist.
Das Request mit QW, meinst du?
Ja, ob das
mittlerweile asynchron ist, weil
wenn ich einen REST
Client baue, möchte ich den auch unbedingt
asynchron machen. Na klar.
Der hatte bloß halt bei sich am Anfang geschrieben,
ich habe überlegt, ob ich eine
asynchrone API dazu anbiete oder
nicht und bei den meisten REST Clients
machst du bestimmt keinen asynchronen Aufruf
und ich denke mir so,
naja, der letzte
REST Client, den ich mal bauen musste für irgendwas,
den habe ich zuerst,
den habe ich erst von Ruby nach Rust portiert
und mir dann gedacht,
nee, ich mache den jetzt einfach mal in JavaScript,
weil Async da noch ein ganzes Stück einfacher ist.
Da war der einfach zehnmal so schnell,
weil bei Rust habe ich mir gedacht,
okay, das könnte ich jetzt hier mit Tokio machen.
Das war an der Stelle noch nicht weit genug,
dass ich das damit hätte machen wollen.
Da konnte ich halt mit Rayon das mal eben schön parallelisieren.
Da ging es auch flott.
Aber dann mit JavaScript einfach mal über eine Schleife
mit 35 Anfragen laufen
und die gleichzeitig alle aufmachen und dann
asynchron drauf warten, dass die irgendwann zurückkommen,
ist wesentlich schneller gewesen zum Schluss.
Das ist auch unglaublich sinnvoll an der Stelle einfach.
Ich meine, gerade wenn du eine reine Liste
an Requests hast, die alle
nacheinander synchron abzuschicken, ist doch einfach nur
dumm. Also, die ist nicht dumm,
aber das ist doch einfach nur unpraktisch.
Die Wartezeit ist doch Quatsch an der Stelle.
Ja, das sind aber Konzepte, die du bis vor ein paar
Jahren nicht hättest anders machen können.
Das ist witzig, wie sich das ausländert.
JavaScript, so
verschrieben wie es ist,
eine der performantesten
Lösungen für viele Sachen.
Du meinst JavaScript,
das Node-basierte JavaScript,
was halt von Haus aus Async ist,
ist ein normales JavaScript ja nicht.
Der große Unterschied zwischen JS und
ECMAScript. Ne, was es asynchron
macht, ne doch quasi,
es ist quasi, JavaScript ist schon immer
irgendwie asynchron gewesen. Naja, ne,
Quatsch, überhaupt nicht, ganz und gar nicht.
Die Art und Weise, wie du programmierst
in JavaScript. Wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel, du gehst
jetzt 15 Jahre zurück und schreibst
JavaScript im Browser. Ja, mein
Machandotter heute noch, da ist nichts Asynchrones dran.
Standardmäßig. Eigentlich
nicht. Was Asynchrones
ist, die Denke, wie du
das ist nicht wirklich Asynchron, aber
die Denke, dass du Events
hast und auf Events-Corebacks registrierst.
Das ist eine Form von Asynchroner
Programmierung. Weil du schreibst ja
User-Interfaces und so ein User, der klickt
mal hier, klickt mal da, da muss der
kommt, wie Events registrieren und auf Sachen
listenen und das ist eine Form von asynchroner
Programmierung. Aber prinzipiell,
da kannst du einfach komplett dein Code hinhacken,
einfach schön sauber,
nicht asynchron. Ja, das wird alles
der Reihe nach ausgeführt.
Das war jetzt, was Node komplett neu gemacht hat,
in dem Moment, wo es rauskam. Ja, Node hat es
einfach, was an Node asynchron ist,
ist, dass du halt im Hintergrund
einen anderen Thread hast,
auf dem du dann
Sachen ausführen lässt und die irgendwann
zurückkommen, die außerhalb von deinem Kontext sind.
Also LibUV, es bietet
dir dann halt ein Interface, um mal eben
Filesystemzugriffe oder
Netzwerkzugriffe asynchron
zu machen. Das heißt, du
gibst deinen Callback für
diesen Event an, du sagst dir, frag mal
diese Webseite ab und dann
ich mach schon mal weiter und dann kommst du halt
irgendwann wieder. Das ist halt diese,
das, was vielen Leuten Probleme macht
bei Callbacks, diese Denke,
warum kann ich denn aus dem Callback nicht einfach ein Ergebnis
rausgeben? Weil es halt noch nicht da
Dieser Ablauf, ich mache jetzt was, dann mache ich eine Abfrage, in der Abfrage reagiere ich dann auf das Ergebnis und danach mache ich weiter, ist halt falsch.
Dadurch, dass es wirklich eigentlich asynchron ist, passieren diese drei Sachen, die du angibst, zu unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten.
Und das ist aber was, was dir die Sprache nicht wirklich vermittelt.
Bei Promise Chaining hast du es dann so ein bisschen mehr rausgekriegt.
Da siehst du dann halt, wenn das, dann das, dann das.
So baust du dir eine Kette auf.
Das kam ja auch erst später dann, dass man das halt sauberer gestalten wollte.
Hier nämlich, ich eigentlich mit Node angefangen habe, das war glaube ich 2013, relativ früh in meinem Studium.
Das hat mich total, richtig fetter Mindfuck war das für mich.
Ich habe nicht verstanden, was genau Asynchronität an der Stelle bedeutet.
Es war Callback-Schachteln bis zum Geht-Nicht-Mehr alles bei mir.
Also I could have stabbed someone with that code.
Das ist immer dieses schöne Beispiel, wenn du halt in die zehnte Ebene reinschachtelst plötzlich.
Ja, das ist schlimm eigentlich.
Aber ich meine, das war halt was komplett anderes von der Denkweise her.
Das war spannend.
Und Promises und Ähnliches
an Futures oder sonst was,
was er heutzutage da reinbringt,
das hatte die Node-Welt damals noch nicht wirklich gebaut gehabt.
Das kam alles ein bisschen später erst.
Ich höre einen Podcast,
der heißt, also manchmal höre ich den,
der heißt JS Party.
Und da reden sie auch über
gewisse Sachen, wo dann einer so
reminisciert hat.
Damals haben wir so und so gebaut,
weil wir die Sprache noch nicht verstanden haben.
Was du machst und wie das machst.
Das ist jetzt auch erst
in den letzten Jahren wirklich den Leuten
berüster geworden, wie man wirklich asynchron arbeitet.
Und dann kamen dann plötzlich Leute und haben gesagt,
wir möchten Futures oder Promises haben.
Dann kam so etwas wie Bluebird und jetzt wurde
Promises in die Sprache eingebaut.
Witzigerweise siehst du aber,
wenn du nochmal Bluebird anguckst,
dass es mehr kann als Standard-Promises.
Das haben wir, glaube ich, schon mal darüber geredet.
Meine Lieblings-Promise-Library ist Pinky-Promise.
Ist das geil oder hat der einen geilen Namen?
Sie hat einen geilen Namen.
Ich habe sie noch nicht benutzt, aber ich sehe sie ja relativ oft
in Benutzung von, ich glaube, diesem
Sintra Sorhus, beziehungsweise dem
Der Hirst, ich habe vergessen, wie er heißt,
zwei Leute, die sehr viel
JavaScript-Fu machen, für mich so
in meiner GitHub-Teilung, die JavaScript-
Gods sind.
Deine JavaScript-Gods?
Machst du JavaScript?
Ich mache nicht viel mit JavaScript, aber ich lese gerne
mal außerhalb meiner Bubble.
Pinky Promise.
JavaScript Promises in 45 Lines of Code.
Ah ja, gut, okay.
kommt in die Shownotes.
Aber wo wir gerade bei JavaScript waren,
können wir eigentlich zu den GitHub-Stars der Woche übergehen.
Mordes, klar.
Also, die stehen jetzt hier
zwar nicht durchmischt, aber wir
können sie trotzdem abwechselnd machen. Also, ich habe hier
zum Spaß einfach mal zwei
JavaScript-GitHub-Stars der Woche
gepickt. Zum Spaß, weil du würdest ja nie ernst
was mit JavaScript machen.
Das Erste,
also, ich habe,
das eine habe ich schon verwendet, das andere
noch nicht, aber ich würde es echt, wenn ich
mal wieder der Use Case ergibt, würde ich
es tatsächlich mal verwenden wollen,
nämlich Shell.js.
Okay, tell me more.
Shell.js ist eine
JavaScript-Library und
die bietet dir einfach eine
JavaScript-eske Funktionalität
zu den meisten bekannten
Shell-Befehlen, sowas wie
Cut, ChangeMod,
CP, Echo,
Dias, Head,
ls, makedir, pwd
und so weiter und so fort. Und dazu halt ein
JavaScript-esches Interface. Das heißt, du kannst Shell-Skripte
dann relativ schnell
nach shell.js umschreiben, indem du einfach
deine ganzen Shell-Befehle
nach dem Shell-Befehl, so wie rm, einfach
dann in String und Klammern machst und
shell.rm in Klammern
mit deinem Strich rf.
Der nächste Befehl ist dann dein Pfad.
Und dann gibt es auch shell.cd
und shell.ls.
Da gab es, glaube ich, irgendwie noch eine Möglichkeit,
dass du
Shell-Skripts
hiervon interpretieren lässt
und dann irgendwie einbittest, aber
auf jeden Fall finde ich es cool, weil
du hast halt die Möglichkeiten von einem
Shell-Skript
erweitert um die Sprachfeatures
von JavaScript, was ja an und für sich
schon eine schöne Sprache ist.
Es gibt wenige Sprachen, die beschissener sind
als JS, aber
Bash-Skripte gezählt auf jeden Fall dazu,
die halt noch mehr Unsicherheiten
bieten, wo Wände, gegen die man spontan
Du weißt zumindest, du hast zumindest bei JavaScript bessere Typen als bei Shell. Bei Shell ist alles ein String. Bei JavaScript kann ich wenigstens strukturierte Datenstrukturen haben in Form von Objekten. Ich weiß, das ist eine Zahl und das ist ein String.
Das stimmt.
Ist das aber nur ein sehr, sehr dünner Rapper
oder macht der auch komischen Magic-Krams,
den du halt, gerade wenn ich das Beispiel
mit MRF sehe, habe ich so ein bisschen Angst,
dass das irgendwas macht, was ich nicht absehen könnte
oder kaut der wirklich? Also wie gesagt, ich habe es noch nicht
wirklich ausprobiert, aber die Dokumentation
ist recht umfangreich und es sieht eigentlich ganz schick aus.
So, das war so dieser
GitHub-Star. Okay.
Ganz kurz dazu.
So, du bist dran.
Ich habe mir ein Rippo rausgesucht,
das heißt Swift AST.
haben es leider noch nicht probieren können,
aber das ist ein
reines Swift-Package,
das es dir erlaubt,
Swift zu parsen und
ein ASD aufzubauen, was ich sehr, sehr cool finde,
weil die Teile vom Compiler, die das machen, kannst du
nicht einfach nutzen, weil das ist ja alles in C++ geschrieben.
Ist das Sourcekit dann quasi?
Also als Alternative zu Sourcekit?
Das macht es auch, ja,
obwohl Sourcekit ist ja eigentlich auch Open Source,
oder zumindest die Teile davon.
Das ist eine interessante Überlegung, da habe ich noch nicht dran gedacht.
Ich wollte dann mal schauen, ob ich vielleicht
mein witziges altes Projekt
Schweil damit durchschreiben kann, weil das macht ja bloß
Stream Replacements auf dein Swift Code, auf dein
Schweil Code. Die Frage ist, ob man das nehmen
könnte, um Swift neu in Swift zu schreiben.
Ja, da fehlt wahrscheinlich noch einiges anderes.
Wenn du den Ast von der Sprache
aufgebaut hast, dann bist du schon mal
relativ weit. Du bist weit, ja,
aber jetzt noch ein Transpiler nach
LVMIR ist das
quasi. Das hat der Rest des Compilers
an der Stelle. Genau.
Ne, interessant,
aber ich wollte gerade rumspielen. Ist auf jeden Fall kurz.
Und ich finde es cool, dass jemand den extrem komplexen Swift-Source mal hier gerappt hat quasi und dafür eine Library bereitstellt.
Weil ich meine, das Swift ist echt keine einfache Sprache.
Syntaktisch ist es unglaublich breit, was teilweise echt ekelhaft wird.
Also ich sehe immer wieder mal in fremden Projekten, oh stimmt, diese Syntax-Front-Interstrukt gab es ja auch, warum nutze ich das eigentlich nicht?
Da fühle ich mich öfter mal witzig.
Ach so, weil es so viel Syntax gibt, dass man...
Ja, Swift hat sehr viel Syntax.
Ich sehe hier gerade, es gibt irgendwie
was ist denn das für eine Syntax?
Eckige
Klammern, das sieht aus wie ein Array,
dann kommt aber Punkt, Target,
wo kommt dieses Punkt? Das nimmt wahrscheinlich
irgendeinen Inam-Wert und
das ist halt
impliziert dann davon das
Element Target.
Okay, ich sehe schon, ich muss mir
mehr Swift angucken. Ich rede nachher noch ein bisschen
über Swift, ich habe noch was Kleines vorbereitet.
Genau, aber
soviel erstmal zu dem Package, finde ich ganz cool, dass das
investiert. Genau. Wie schaut es bei dir aus?
Was hast du denn? Du noch.
Ich habe hier gerade noch was gefunden, was ich
schon vor drei Wochen in dieses Bett reingeschmissen habe
und selber gerade noch mal reingucken musste.
Luftdaten.info
Okay. Was ist das? Das ist nicht wirklich
ein GitHub-Star, aber es ist so eine Art Pick.
Und das ist eine Webseite
vom OKLab Stuttgart.
Das OKFM-Projekt. Ja, das ist sehr cool.
Und die haben quasi eine Map
mit Karten,
eine Map mit Luftqualität.
Ich liebe solche Hacks-Maps.
Genau, und dann haben die hier quasi eine Anleitung für so Luftqualitätsmessstationen.
Und dann kannst du quasi, guck mal rein, Dresden gibt es auch schon.
Und die Luftqualität hier, ja, ist einigermaßen okay.
Es gibt ja irgendwo Richtung Blasegewitz gibt es dann irgendwie so ein gelberes,
wo ich momentan noch nicht mal, das misst glaube ich Parts per Million, also Luftverschmutzung.
Es gibt ein Messer, eine Messstation in der Neustadt.
gibt es irgendwas hier am Campus,
wo mich das wundert, es müsste hier
Richtung Rest, hier steht,
dass das irgendwie Ecke Zellischer Weg,
Ecke Bergstraße ist, da müsste eigentlich die Luftqualität
super schlecht sein.
Aber schaut euch das mal an, ich finde
es cool, wenn es noch mehr so
Luftqualitätsmessstationen gäbe,
dass es sich irgendwie vielleicht irgendwann
als App sich angucken könnte, wie ist denn
hier so die Luftqualität? Weil ich denke mir zum Beispiel
jeden Tag, ich fahre mit dem Fahrrad,
das ist auch gut und ich habe auch jetzt
auf
Deutschlandfunk Nova von so einer Studie gehört,
dass du als Autofahrer
halt sehr viel
Schadstoffbelastung ausgesetzt bist,
selbst im Auto.
Und ich denke mir,
ich fahre Fahrrad, aber auf der anderen Seite,
ich fahre halt die beiden
schnellsten Wege von mir zu meinem
Arbeitsplatz, führen halt an den Hauptverkehrsstraßen
in Dresden lang. Und wenn ich da
mit dem Fahrrad lang düse und dabei,
weil ich Sport mache, quasi schwer atme,
dann ziehe ich mir auch eine ganze Menge Feinstaub rein.
Ja, klar.
Deswegen finde ich es mal spannend, wenn es irgendwie ein genaueres Netz an solchen Messstationen gäbe.
Du kannst ja eine mobile Messstation in deinem Fahrrad basteln, wo du dann quasi noch einen GPS-Chip mit dran hast.
Das ist natürlich auch krass. Da hast du wie so ein Periskop, wo dann vorne die Luft so reinweht beim Fahrradfahren.
Legascheiß.
Ich stehe manchmal, wenn ich fahre an Ampeln, stehe ich mitten auf der Straße.
dann zum Beispiel hier,
wo es von der Nötnütze runter
die Münchner Straße geht,
da stehe ich halt auf der Straße, weil ich links abbiege,
da stehe ich halt teilweise hinter Autos. Wenn die losfahren,
dann habe ich sofort was reingehört.
Na klar, das ist auf jeden Fall.
Also luftdaten.info
Sehr cool.
Das war doch dieses Hardware-Projekt, wo du das auch selber
schön basteln kannst und dann einfach die
daheim hinlegst und die Daten mit zu denen schickst, um
zu den dezentralen zu agregieren.
Das ist cool. Cooles Projekt.
Sehr gutes Projekt.
So, noch was da von dir?
Ich habe noch ein Projekt, was in der Public Transport Organisation auf GitHub liegt.
Das ist quasi eine Art des Public Shaming bzw. Public auf den Rücken klatschen.
Ist das nicht das, was du angefangen hattest, was dir dann von den Leuten übernommen wurde?
Genau, die Org, aber nicht das Repo.
The State of the Open heißt das Repo und das ist einfach The State of Open Public Transport.
Eine Sammlung von Public Transport Providern, aktuell nur der VWB.
Und was für Daten haben die?
In welchem Zustand sind die Daten?
Und so weiter.
Und das finde ich eine sehr, sehr coole Sache.
Und ich würde da gerne auch mal VVO-Kram dazu
Pull-Bequesten.
Und die auch mal schön aufbereiten und sammeln.
Das heißt, es ist einfach bloß eine
Stelle, an der die
APIs dokumentiert sind.
Weniger Doku, mehr so. Was gibt's?
Und wie scheiße ist das?
Ach so.
Was ich spannend finde, wäre eigentlich so eine
Hattest du das nicht sogar mal angefangen?
So eine Feature-Karte? Ich kriege das und das?
aus diesen APIs raus und sowas.
Wenn ich jetzt in Dresden bin, kann ich
mir angucken, an welche Haltestelle wann welche
Bussen und Bahnen kommen und wo die hinfahren.
Und wenn ich jetzt in Leipzig
bin, könnte ich das eventuell nicht. Oder wenn ich
jetzt in Stuttgart bin, kann ich aber noch das und das
mehr, was ich in Dresden nicht kann.
Wo mir auch da letztens aufgefallen ist, dass die
Datenqualität sehr unterschiedlich ist.
In Dresden gibt es, für uns
beim VVO gibt es drei verschiedene
APIs, die du erhitten
kannst, um aktuelle Abfahrten an einer
Haltestelle zu bekommen. Und ich
letztens an einer Haltestelle und habe
eine dieser API Endpoints,
der von einem Telegram-Bot gerappt wurde,
von Dirk, falls Dirk das hört, hi Dirk,
benutzt, um
zu schauen, wann kommt denn die nächste Bahn, weil das
die schnellste Möglichkeit ist. Akronomisierbar,
der Podcast, wo gegrüßt wird.
Ja, aber der Telegram-Bot
finde ich recht angenehm in der Nutzung, weil du schickst
dir deine Location, was Telegram sehr einfach macht
und der sagt dir, gibt dir direkt so eine
Vorschlagstastatur, hey, willst du die Abfahrten für diese
Haltestelle in deiner Nähe oder diese in deiner Nähe oder diese in deiner Nähe?
Das macht er die Interaktion sehr schnell,
dass ich über eine andere Möglichkeit kenne.
Und der Telegram dort sagte mir,
dass in den nächsten 20 Minuten alles nur in die falsche Richtung fährt.
Nichts in meine Richtung, fand ich sehr verwirrend.
Dachte mir, muss ein Bug sein.
Habe die offizielle DVB-App genutzt.
Die sagte, klar, deine Bahn kommt in 10 Minuten.
Da habe ich schon mal diese Dresden-Fahr-Info-App benutzt,
die den anderen Endpoint nutzt.
Und auch die sagte, die nächste Bahn kommt in 10 Minuten.
Tatsächlich kam da aber nichts.
Und der DVB-Twitter-Feed ließ mich darauf schließen,
dass ein Unfall passiert.
ist, kurz vor meiner Haltestelle.
Das heißt, die eine API bietet dir Live-Daten
und die anderen bloß so irgendwelche Schedule-Daten.
Da ist es anscheinend nicht aufgetaucht. Ich dachte eigentlich,
dass das mehr Live-Daten sind als der andere
Endpoint, aber tatsächlich hat
dieser, wie ich hinein identifiziere,
der Widget-Endpoint, die echtesten
Daten in Anführungsstrichen. Was mich
sehr irritiert, weil das ist für mich der
älteste, komischste Endpoint.
Da fällt mir gerade ein, bei dem, das Thema
DVB, was man so
als schnelles
Beispiel einfällt, kam halt bei dem
Speedup auf auf und da hat einer das
dvb-Crate gefunden, das gleich mal
ausprobiert und da kommen momentan
keine Daten aus diesem Monitor-Info-Endpoint,
den ich da implementiert habe, woraus haben sich da
eventuell die API geändert?
Die haben ein paar Details an dem eigentlichen
Endpoint geändert. Du musst irgendwelche Parameter,
das haben irgendwelche anderen Default-Werte und du musst
irgendwelche mitschicken. Da kannst du mir ja nachher mal einen Pull-Request schicken, oder?
Ich kann nochmal überlegen, was da sich
geändert hat. Das habe ich in dvb-go,
hat mir das Lutz, hi Lutz,
als Pull-Request geschickt.
Wie Leute haben wir schon gegrüßt?
Drei aktuell in dieser Folge,
wenn ich nicht mitgezählt habe.
Nee, aber das Repo,
Public Style, Transport Style, The Open, ich finde es eine coole Idee
und ich mag solche, ich wollte es vielleicht mal machen
mit maschinenlesbaren Daten, habe mir actually die Domain
maschinenlesbar.de gekauft, das ist noch nichts.
Gibt es nicht.ar?
Nee, Quatsch,
maschinenles.bar.
Aber bar ist so teuer.
Maschinenles.bar
wäre gut. Okay, nee, maschinenlesbar.de
Demnächst mit Inhalt.
Da ist schon eine Seite, aber die ist halt
ein hässlicher Placeholder, weil ich dann
nie wieder so gedacht hatte, was zu machen.
Egal. Hast du noch
einen GitHub-Star? Ja, ich habe noch eine
kleine, coole JavaScript-Library.
Und zwar
Microsignals heißt die.
Ist auch in den Show Notes. Und zwar
Signals sind eine andere Art und Weise,
Logik in JavaScript zusammenzuknüppern.
Wenn du schon mal
Qt gemacht hast, da gibt es ja auch Signals und Slots.
Das ist hier ein bisschen ähnlich.
Es gibt mehrere Implementationen
von Signals. Sind das so wie die Signals aus der
RX-Welt oder was?
Ein Signal ist quasi,
ist einfach erst mal ein Objekt
und auf das kannst du dann Listener adden
und dann kannst du drauf das patchen.
Okay, dann ist das glaube ich die indische Idee.
Genau, das heißt, du hast es irgendwo rumliegen, du hast
so ein Signal und dann
kannst du halt mehrere, was habe ich gerade
schon gesagt, ich habe das zum Beispiel für dieses Spiel,
was ich vor ein paar Jahren mal in CoffeeScript gebaut habe,
sehr exzessiv genutzt, weil du halt Events
damit verknüppern kannst. Du hast halt unterschiedliche
Stellen, wo dann die abgehört
Ich mag das Wort verknüppern.
Genau.
Und was
Microsignals halt ausmacht,
ist zum einen, dass es doch
dafür, dass es sehr viel macht, schön klein ist.
Der Autor
hat auch auf dem
Readme stehen, das hat übrigens nichts mit
Minisignals zu tun. Mir war nicht bekannt,
das ist auch schon eine Minisignals-Library.
Also Nanosignals kommt demnächst?
Ja,
vielleicht.
Zumindest
ist in TypeScript geschrieben, das hat auch ein TypeScript-esches
Interface. Was ich cool finde,
das sind so Features, die
vielleicht aus dem
Functional Programming-Umfeld kennst
und Bluebird hat sowas halt auch.
Du kannst auf dem Signal,
wenn du dich als Listener addest, kannst du da
vorher auch noch sagen, Map und Filter.
Das heißt, du hast das Signal und dann sagst du
und da fallen halt
Sachen raus, weil da irgendwie am Ende
einer die ganze Zeit Zahlen oder Uhrzeiten
und irgendwelche bestimmten Sachen reinschmeißt. Da kannst du halt sagen,
ich möchte mich darauf registrieren, aber ich möchte nicht,
das Signal direkt haben,
sondern ich möchte ein gemapptes Signal haben,
wo dann alle Events erstmal durch
dieses Lambda, durch diese
Filterfunktion durch müssen
und dann kannst du es noch,
Filter war jetzt das blöde Wort, und dann kannst du es halt noch filtern.
Das heißt, du kannst sagen,
hier ist übrigens das Signal und dann sage ich
Map, Filter, Add
und dann fügst du dich als
Listener hinzu und hast es aber halt nur ein
Subset von den Sachen, die dich wirklich interessieren
und du hast es vorher
nochmal ein bisschen angepasst und verstanden. Das ist eigentlich ziemlich geil.
Ein schönes Beispiel dafür fand ich immer gerade aus der,
fällt jetzt dazu immer dieses RxSwift-Project ein,
aber es sind ja diese ganzen RxLibs für quasi jede Sprache,
die eine sehr ähnliche API haben
und quasi auf Signals und Observables und so weiter basieren.
Und ich fand einmal ein schönes Beispiel für,
du hast eine iOS-App, das ist ein Textfeld,
und der Nutzer tippt dieses Textfeld ein
und du willst dafür Request an eine API schicken.
Und zum einen willst du, dass der Nutzer beim Tippen nicht,
du willst nicht jedes Zeichen sofort abschicken.
Das heißt, du machst erstmal,
die genauen Begrifflichkeiten jetzt vergessen,
dann liegt es einfach so ein Delay drauf, dass erst wenn der Nutzer
nur 3 Sekunden beispielsweise,
nichts getippt hat, schickst du ein Request ab
und dann kannst du die auch canceln, wenn der Nutzer
weiter tippt und erst ab 3 Zeichen wird überhaupt eins geschickt,
das ist sicherlich super schön, mit
Signals auf dem Text-Content von diesem Textfeld
einfach mit drauflegen, das sind einfach
die drei Funktionen, die du drüberlegst und dann hast du das,
was du in sonst sehr komplexer Logik auf klassische
Art und Weise bauen müsstest, da zusammen
gerappt, nur als ein Beispiel,
aber diese RX-Libs
sind generell ziemlich cool und die haben auch so eine wunderschöne
Ich weiß nicht, ob du die kennst, rxmarbles.com.
Nee, aber die kommen jetzt hoffentlich in die Show-Notes.
Die kommen auf jeden Fall in die Show-Notes.
Das sage ich auch noch hoffentlich.
Du bist derjenige, der es zum Schluss machen muss.
Ja, ich habe es gerne mal dazu.
Wo steht rx jetzt mal für mich?
Reactive-Kram.
Also ich meine,
Reactive-Programming ist mir ein Begriff.
Aber ich muss sagen,
das sind so Sachen, die kannst du wirklich nur
interessant nutzen, wenn du
Front-End-Entwicklung machst,
wenn du User-Interfaces baust.
Naja, nicht unbedingt.
Die Idee ist ja nicht so anders.
Ich meine, interaktive Sachen hauptsächlich.
Ach so, ja, okay.
Das ist ja die Definition von User-Interface,
wenn interaktiv irgendwas ist.
Aber das mache ich halt leider nicht so häufig.
Manchmal bin ich auch froh, dass ich das...
Manchmal muss ich das machen,
wenn ich auf Arbeit irgendwie ein Feature einbaue
und das dann auch noch in der Oberfläche der Anwendung mit anbieten muss.
Macht manchmal auch Spaß, aber es ist eine Riesenfrickelei.
UI-Code ist immer eine Riesen-Frickelei.
Generell, der noch nie was Schönes gefunden hat.
Ich hasse es wie die Pest.
Mein ungeliebtester Teil an jedem Projekt
ist letztendlich das User-Interface-Basteln.
Ja, deswegen baue ich auch in meiner Freizeit
fast ausschließlich Kommandozeile.
Ja, das war viel angenehmer, tausendmal angenehm.
Ich habe meine Diplomarbeit über User-Interface-Engineering
geschrieben und ich liebe es auch,
mich damit auseinanderzusetzen,
aber das tatsächliche Umsetzen von User-Interface
ist eine Scheißarbeit.
Obwohl auch ein schönes User-Interface haben möchte.
Ein Kommandozeileninterface ist einfach
ein schönes Kommandozeileninterface,
ist aber auch echt was wert.
Weil du quasi eine Sprache definierst,
mit der du mit der Anwendung redest.
Du meinst, das SLA-Interface
ist quasi auch wieder eine DSL-Gruppe?
Ja, wenn du eine Bash-Anwendung schreibst,
dann benutzt du ja quasi auch das
Kommandozeileninterface von den einzelnen Anwendungen
als Funktionsaufrufe in deinem
Bash-Skript.
Stimmt.
Soviel zum Thema Microsignals.
Genau. Ich habe noch einen letzten Star.
Der ist relativ klein.
Das Ding ist ein wunderschönes kleines JavaScript-Projekt
namens Gender Regex,
was dir eine Regex in die Hand gibt,
die valide Gender Identifier matcht.
Also ich habe mir das angeguckt.
Du hast eine Funktion, der gibt es dann Stream rein
und die gibt dann einfach True oder False zurück.
Die gibt dir zurück, ist das ein Gender Identifier oder nicht.
Ah ja.
Das denkst du dir, das ist eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Aber wie zum Geier machen die das?
Und die Regings ist einfach nur
Punktlernchen. Also alles ist
ein sehr politisches Projekt.
Ich fand es trotzdem cool.
Ich mag solche kleinen
Spaßprojekten. Also ich weiß nicht, ob mich jetzt jemand
auf die Füße tritt, wenn ich sage, das ist ein Spaßprojekt, aber
natürlich würde niemand das einbinden in
seine Codebase. Das wäre ja einfach dumm.
Können wir irgendwie rückwärts grappen, wer das
schon gemacht hat und wer nicht?
Du kannst ja immer auf NPM schauen, wenn das auf NPM liegt,
was die Dependents davon sind.
So, jetzt muss ich das tatsächlich machen.
Gender
Regexen. Auf der GitHub-Seite ist natürlich
nicht verlinkt, ob
das bei NPM schon
hochgeladen wurde.
NPM, JS,
langsam, Gender,
Regex.
Naja, ich glaube nicht,
dass es das gibt. Doch, da.
Tatsächlich. 1.0
Regex. Und der macht
28 Downloads
in Last Month.
Dependence?
Dependenz, dachte ich,
wird ja auch gelistet.
oder juristipendenziell, wie immer du es merken möchtest.
Offenbar nicht so viele.
Oder vielleicht sind die nicht gelistet.
Also baut mal Gender-Reg-Ex in eurer Anwendung.
Ich meine, das ist Quatsch.
Das ist zu übernehmen in deinem Projekt.
Du sollst einfach nur wissen,
dass es halt, wenn du genderbasiert Dinge machst,
dass du darüber nachdenkst.
Das ist auch das Geile,
wenn du dich irgendwo anmeldest auf irgendeiner Website
und die, wo erstmal dein Gender wissen,
warum braucht das sowas?
Das fand ich krass.
Du hast ja auch eine Weile in den USA gelebt.
Ich bin für ein Jahr zur Highschool gegangen dort
und wenn du da so einen Test ausfüllst
an der Highschool,
ich glaube, bei den SATs mitgemacht oder sowas,
da hast du am Anfang ein relativ umfangreiches
Feld, wo du dich selber beschreiben musst.
Nicht nur Name, Vorname, Alter,
Geschlecht, sondern auch noch
Race. Ich finde es bei den Amis
super krass, dass die das als Race bezeichnen.
Da gab es halt Checkboxes
und da gab es,
ich weiß nicht, ob es Black-White hieß,
aber das war es zumindest mit dabei.
Dann gab es Hispanic, dann gab es
Asian und dann
Upper oder was?
Dann gab es noch, dann gab es glaube ich sogar Eskimo
oder sowas, stand mir drauf.
Okay, wo warst du in den USA?
Ich war in Georgia.
Okay, also eher Südstaaten.
Ich habe dann zumindest immer, ich habe dann
was Abgefahrenes angekreuzt.
What the fuck?
Mich stört es schon, dass die Amis,
nee anders,
nicht die Amis,
aber das ist in den USA
relativ normal,
dass man von Race redet.
Ja, das ist komisch.
Und das finde ich schon rassistisch, muss ich sagen.
Da gibt es übrigens einen sehr guten Film, der heißt Race.
Handelt von einem Läufer.
Deswegen der zweite Räger-Titel.
Der Typ ist schwarz und hat, glaube ich,
damals in der zweiten Weltkriegszeit
und Olympische Spiele irgendwie was.
Ich weiß nicht, ich komme mal von einem Namen.
Das ist nicht, glaube ich, irgendwas.
Der hat noch Skandal ausgelöst,
weil er mit Adidas-Schuhen in Deutschland
irgendwie Rekorde aufgestellt hat.
Ein guter Film, habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Das steht auch für seit Ewigkeit auf meiner Watchlist.
Habe ihn leider noch nicht gesehen.
Ja, zumindest.
Es gibt keine Menschenrassen.
Das ist Quatsch.
Wenn du es auf Deutsch sagst, klingt es halt richtig krass.
Aber im Englischen
ist es noch, im Amerikanischen
ist es noch so
en vaut und normal, dass du über Race redest.
Das ist komisch. Es fühlt sich ja komisch an.
Ich meine, es ist ja,
okay, jetzt ist es übergeben,
ein gefährliches Gewässer. Es ist ja nicht so, als ob so Dinge
wie unterschiedliche Hautfarben nicht existieren würden.
Aber die spielen eine viel zu krasse Rolle
im Alltag.
Was sie überhaupt gar nicht haben sollten.
Nee, ja.
Race wäre, wenn unterschiedliche Menschen
aus unterschiedlichen Regionen nicht Homo sapiens
wären. Aber wir sind einfach bloß
die Menschen auf der Welt, die haben einfach
bloß unterschiedliche
Aussehenseigenschaften. Das ist alles.
Ja, ja.
Das ist im biologischen Sinne, ist es auch gar keine Rasse, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das, dafür gibt es
eventuell einen Begriff. Es gibt ja
Biologie, es gibt ja
Familien und Typos und Arten
und Rassen und unterschiedliche Abstufungen
von, also
Menschen und Sonnenblumen sind halt
komplett unterschiedliche und jetzt weiß ich nicht, wie der Begriff
dafür heißt, aber eine Rasse ist halt
wirklich was
weitaus unterschiedlicheres
als was du bei Menschen findest.
Okay, Hunderassen zum Beispiel?
Wie ist das da? Bei Hunderassen
ist es schwierig, weil Hunderassen gibt es auch also seit
100.000 Jahren. Ich weiß nicht, ob da...
Hunderassen können sich zumindest auch
untereinander noch... Das sind ja alle quasi
dasselbe...
Begrifflichkeit hier einfügen, was auch immer passt.
Ich glaube, Rassen,
der Begriff Rasse kommt dann ins Spiel,
wenn sich zwei Lebewesen nicht mehr
gemeinsam paaren und
Weibler nachdenken.
Dann dürfte man ja nicht von Hunderassen sprechen,
dann wäre das ja falsch.
Aber zumindest selbst bei Hunderassen
gibt es größere Unterschiede als zwischen Menschen.
Es ist nicht so, dass der eine Mensch
achtmal so groß ist wie der andere.
Echt krass.
Allein wenn man das Wort Rasse in den Mund nimmt,
fühlt man sich schon wie so ein Nazi.
Das ist echt krass.
Das rief sich richtig ekelhaft an.
Aber wenn du auf Englisch redest
mit Amnesty, ist das halt
wesentlich normaler.
Komisch.
So viel zum Thema,
so viel zur politischen Sektion.
Gut, dass wir die Gender-Regals dringelassen haben,
damit wir fünf Sekunden drüber sprechen und dann
trotzdem ausatmen.
So viel zur...
Gut, kommen wir zum Experiment der Woche.
Oh, hast du was vorbereitet?
Ich habe gerade eine
Shameless eine Sektion aus einer anderen Podcast-Reihe
geklaut. Also ein kleines
Spielchen, was ihr vielleicht zu Hause mal ausprobieren
könnt, was mir bloß neulich mal aufgefallen ist, weil ich es aus
ein paar YouTube-Videos gelernt habe und es ist ein schönes
Experiment, was man zu Hause auch selber
ausprobieren kann. Dafür braucht man
allerdings sowas.
Was ist das? Ein Fidget-Spinner.
Vermutlich kein Fidget-Spinner, sondern
ein Off-Brand-Widget-Spinner
oder was auch immer. Ja, keine Ahnung.
Aus irgendeinem Grund habe ich so einen kleinen
Drehkörper hier
Video von Smarter Every Day,
wo er den Rolling Shutter Effekt erklärt hat.
Stimmt. Das ist ein gutes Video.
Und das Rolling Shutter
Effekt heißt quasi, deine Kamera,
die du an deinem Handy hast, die du zweimal an deinem Handy hast,
die du an deinem Laptop hast, überall hast,
die funktioniert halt
so, dass sie die einzelnen
Sensoren, Zeilen
auf dem Sensor der Reihe nach ablichtet,
weshalb unterschiedliche Bereiche
im Bild zu einem unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkt aufgenommen
wurden.
Das kannst du auch schön sehen, wenn du mal
Auto fährst, möglichst wenn du Beifahrer
bist, oder wenn du
Zug fährst, wenn du dein Handy
aus dem Fenster hältst, siehst du,
dass alles so leicht gekippt aussieht.
Wenn du das Handy umdrehst, kippt es in die andere Richtung,
weil der Sensor halt dann andersrum
liegt. Das ist witzig.
Beim Experiment der Woche habe ich jetzt hier mal
Fotogooth aufgemacht, also
die Selfie-Anwendung auf meinem Laptop.
Die Selfie-Anwendung. Und wenn ich da
jetzt diesen Fidget-Spinner in die Kamera
halte, siehst du einfach lustige Effekte,
entstehen. Das könnt ihr einfach mal selber zu Hause
ausprobieren. Das fiel mir bloß gerade zum Spaß ein.
So, und man sieht dann meistens, dass
auf der linken Seite das Bild ein bisschen
anders aussieht als auf der rechten.
Und jetzt wandern diese Dinge,
diese Punkte wieder in die andere Richtung.
Aber hat das mit Rolling Shutter
zu tun, dass sich quasi schnell
bewegende Objekte in Videos
aussehen, als ob sie langsam in die andere Richtung
drehen? Das kommt noch
mit der Abtastfrequenz,
es hängt noch mit Abtastfrequenz zu tun.
Achso, dass es halt zufälligerweise genau da passt,
dass es halt so aussieht, dass es langsam ist.
Wenn deine Abtastfrequenz
minimal langsamer ist
als deine Rotationsfrequenz,
dann sieht es halt so aus, als ob sich das Objekt rückwärts
dreht.
Auch wenn du einen Helikopter filmst,
oder wenn du den
Uhrzeiger mal als Beispiel nimmst,
das Ding dreht sich halt
mehrmals pro
Frame, aber nicht ganz, dann ist es halt beim nächsten
Frame nicht ganz
wieder bis auf 12 und dann bloß bis 11,
sondern beim nächsten bist du wieder bloß bis 10
gekommen, dann bist du bloß bis 9 und dann hast du halt den Eindruck,
dass es zurück werden muss.
Zufällig genau an der Frequenz rankommen, in die Nähe davon, stimmt.
Gibt das total Sinn.
Aber zu dem Oren-Shutter-Video von
2,3,4 Days, hast du mir letztens gezeigt gehabt.
Der hat unglaublich schöne Visualisierungen
dafür. Schau dich das wirklich mal an.
Das ist ein sehr cooles Video.
Dann gab es einen Typen, der hat gesagt,
das ist ein totaler Scheiß gewesen,
hauptsächlich weil ich selber so ein Video
neulich erst machen wollte und du bist mir einen Tag
Und du musst übrigens nicht mit einer Highspeed-Kamera hingehen
und irgendwelche großen Flugzeugrotoren abfotografieren.
Ich habe hier was gebastelt und dann hat er einfach auf einen Akkuschrauber
so einen kleinen Ventilator draufgeklebt und den gedreht.
Und dann hat er mit dem gleichen OpenCV-Filter quasi dann das Bild so nachbearbeitet,
dass du da den gleichen Effekt siehst.
Und das für halt ein paar Euro.
Du musst das halt ein paar Zeilen Python dafür schreiben.
witzig.
Was er dann auch gezeigt hat, ist, dass du einfach
auf einen Flachbett-Scanner eine Uhr
legst oder irgendwas anderes legst und das während
der das abscannt, langsam drehst, dann hast du
denselben Effekt. Stimmt, klar.
Cool.
So.
Wir haben noch andere Themen.
Wir haben Themenvorschläge bekommen von
Zuhörern unserer Sendung.
Nämlich vom Herrn Schmidtlauch.
Hi, Herr Schmidtlauch.
Der hatte gemeint, wir sollen mal über Wim Penderk reden.
Die Latech-Pest im Allgemeinen.
Hat er den Begriff Latech-Pest?
Das musst du sagen, das weiß ich leider nicht mehr.
Er hat uns
ein Issue auf GitHub geschrieben.
Die Latech-Pest im Allgemeinen ist schön.
Ja, Pendoc ist ein unglaublich cooles Tool.
Wir hatten ja vorhin mal ganz kurz darüber gequatscht,
dass das ja quasi
ein Transpiler ist.
Also was ist Pendoc jetzt überhaupt?
Pendoc ist ein,
Pendoc ist das Beispielprojekt,
was in Hesky geschrieben wird, aber die Pendoc ist
ein wunderschönes, ganz Programm,
hast du Dokumente in einen Format
in ein beliebiges anderes Format konvertiert.
Also von jetzt Markdown zu LaTeX,
zu, keine Ahnung, Open Office Document,
zu HTML, zu und so weiter und so fort.
Genau.
Es gibt auf der Webseite,
gibt es halt diese schöne Visualisierung,
da hast du halt ganz viele unterschiedliche Formate,
links in so einen Kasten reingehen,
auf dem Kasten steht Pandoc raus
und rechts kommen halt ganz viele andere Pfeile raus
mit anderen Formaten.
Also es ist quasi ein Transpiler.
Ja.
Und wie gesagt,
das Beispielprojekt,
Für mich das Beispielprojekt, für ein
Haskell-Projekt, was viele Leute nutzen.
Aber so was in Haskell geschrieben wird.
Ja, Haskell,
da habe ich dann halt zynischerweise gesagt,
es ist halt so eine Art Compiler.
Das ist halt das, was du in Haskell am ehesten machen kannst,
weil du weißt genau, was reinkommt und was
auf der anderen Seite wieder rausgeht.
Aber ja, ist ganz cool.
Ich habe den Eindruck, die meisten Leute verwenden es vornehmlich
für
Markdown nach Latich.
Dafür nutze ich es auch wieder mal.
Also ich habe meine Diplomarbeit damit geschrieben.
Das heißt, du kannst da nicht komplett alles mitmachen.
Ich habe dann alles in Markdown geschrieben,
aber mit LaTeX hatte ich schon eine wesentlich höhere Mächtigkeit
als Markdown selber.
Und dementsprechend habe ich einfach mit die einzelnen Dateien
als Markdown geschrieben
und das dann mit einem Make-File gebaut,
was das dann in LaTeX umgewandelt
und ein größeres LaTeX-Projekt eingebunden hat.
Hat an einem bestimmten Punkt dann aufgehört,
wo ich zum Beispiel sowas wie
Bildunterschriften
machen wollte, das ging dann
mit Markdown, selbst mit dem
erweiterten Markdown-Dialekt von Pendock nicht mehr.
Da musste ich dann anfangen, so inline-latig
zu machen, das ist auch ein bisschen blöd.
Dann wird es ja echt damit widerlich.
Genau.
Was genau ist das Wim-Pendock?
Sagt mir gerade gar nichts.
Wim-Pendock ist dann einfach ein Plugin für Wim.
Das heißt, die einfache Plugin für Wim,
schreib mal einfach ein Plugin für Wim, das musst du mit
Wim-L machen, mit dieser Wim-Sprache.
Was dir dann einfach eine Integration
in dein Editor anbietet und sagt,
den aktuellen Buffer
zu beliebig Kot-Output-Kommentieren.
Ja, genau. Und das ist highlighted
halt noch schön, dass
Mark dann, was du schreibst.
Ich hoffe, ich werde dem jetzt hier nicht,
ich bin dem jetzt nicht ungerecht,
aber über den Pandoc
macht bestimmt noch eine ganze Menge mehr.
Über die LATIC-PEST
im Allgemeinen haben wir aber mal
gerantet, schon mal ganz kurz, oder?
Ich meine da
mich grob dran zu erinnern, dass da schon mal was
gewesen ist.
Ich schlage regelmäßig vor, dass
Latech allein
aufgrund seiner Funktionalität schon eine
Berechtigung hat, aber die Sprache,
die man dazu schreiben muss, die kann man halt gerne
wegschmeißen und durch was anderes ersetzen.
Und
auch die Trennung von Inhalt
und Sprache ist halt nicht wirklich
schön genug, aber das kannst du auch nicht damit
ersetzen, dass du sowas wie
Pendock schreibst.
Sowas wie Markdown schreibst.
und per Noc davor hängst und dann
es übersetzt.
Zumindest nicht komplett.
Dann hast du halt nicht die gesamte Mächtigkeit davon abgedeckt.
Das ist spannend, weil
sowas wie Latich habe ich, also
Latich ist ja auch kein
neues Projekt,
aber
sowas in der Richtung habe ich tatsächlich
noch nicht gesehen, neu
fancy, es sei denn, man spricht jetzt von sowas
wie Markdown, aber so komplett mit
hier wunderschönes Typesetting und
Kram und
ich kenne kein Beispiel für,
das hat mal jemand versucht neu zu bauen.
Ja, das ist ja auch eine
Schweinearbeit. Sicherlich, klar.
Aber Leute machen sowas.
Ich habe ein kleines Projekt, wo
ich PDF-Dateien erzeuge
und da war auch das naheliegendste
Latich zu nehmen, um dann
irgendwelche Latich-Dokumente auszufüllen und
die dann durch Latich zu jagen, weil
Latich ist halt fertig
und es ist auch ein abgeschlossenes
Ding, was du fast
überall installiert bekommst, ist es natürlich ein riesen
Rattenschwanz, den du mit
installieren musst.
Riesen Rattenschwanz, da fällt mir gerade was Schönes.
Ich habe eine Geschichte im Radio
mitgehört, da ging es um
so Live-Harräder auf der Straße
und unterschiedliche Anbieter.
Da wollte dann
einer, der geinterviewt wurde,
der wollte sagen, da hängt ein
langer Rattenschwanz hinten dran.
Aber die anderen haben gesagt, da hängt ein Riesenschwanz
dran.
Okay.
Ja, es tut mir leid, wir haben aus dem Thema
jetzt hier nicht rausholen können.
Nee, also Pendoc, Wim Pendoc bringt halt
hier noch so ein bisschen
visivikartige
Funktionalität im Editor mit.
Achso, Table of Contents bietet es dir an.
Das sind andere. Also das habe ich
auch benutzt. Das heißt, du schreibst
deinen Markdown und kriegst halt im Wim
Table of Content angezeigt.
Wo ich da echt sagen muss, also
Wim ist auch mein absoluter Lieblingseditor,
aber für sowas wie Pendoc
möchte ich dann doch eher einen wirklich
visivikartigeren Editor haben. Also was die hier machen,
ist, du gehst auf eine Zeile, wenn du eine Zeile
mit Wim Pendock nicht anfokussierst,
dann siehst du nicht den, zum Beispiel
die drei
Rauten vorne für den Titel
oder die Bullet Points
als tatsächliche Zeichen,
die du getippt hast, sondern die werden durch etwas Hübscheres
ersetzt. Das ist die
visivik Funktionalität von Wim Pendock.
Aber tatsächlich, wenn ich Pendock
schreibe für irgendwelche Readmeans, dann nehme ich am liebsten dann doch
irgendwie sowas wie Type Horror
oder irgendwas, was es dann schöner für mich rendert.
Genau.
Ja, kommen wir weiter.
Ich habe letztens Lust gehabt,
ein kleines Tool zu schreiben,
das für das Swift-Ecosystem
ein bisschen das Leben vereinfacht.
Und so habe ich letztens einfach ein paar Mal öfter
eine Swift CLI für irgendwas schreiben
oder ein kleines Tool schreiben wollen, CLI meist,
die in Swift implementiert ist
und irgendwas macht, was auch immer,
sei es jetzt ein Telegram-Bot oder irgendein Tool,
das man einfach in den Noten von der Uni abruft und ausgibt und sonst was.
Also wenn du eine Kommandosalien-Anwendung brauchst,
eine kleine, dann schreibst du wirklich als erstes zu Swift, ja?
Ich wollte einfach mal sehen,
also das hat sich ja jetzt lange entwickelt
und ist ja irgendwo angekommen.
Es entwickelt sich.
Genau, es entwickelt sich.
Das Problem, in das ich bloß reingerannt bin,
ist, dass es in der Swift-Welt so ist,
dass der Swift-Package-Manager keinen zentralen Package-Index hat,
sondern die Packages über ein beliebiges Git-Report zieht.
Und dieses Git-Report liegt halt irgendwo,
meist 99% der Fälle auf GitHub,
aber die Discoverability von den Packages
ist halt totaler Mist.
Also du findest nicht Packages.
Ich dachte, ich wollte irgendwas machen,
wollte mal auf Dateien zugreifen
und die Standard-System-File-APIs
sind halt ein bisschen ekelhaft.
Da gibt es aber schon einen schönen Rapper für.
Du musst erstmal eine Ewigkeit rumsuchen auf GitHub,
bevor du was gefunden hast.
Und da gibt es schon zwei, drei Seiten,
die da versucht haben,
ein bisschen was auf die Beine zu stellen,
unter anderem von IBM tatsächlich.
IBM und Apple sind da recht dicke, was
Swift angeht. Ja stimmt, IBM
investiert relativ stark in Swift.
Genau. Du, mich, kannst
du auch Swift-Dinge direkt deployen.
Spannend.
Jedenfalls haben die Package-Catalog.com
ins Leben gerufen, was letztendlich
ein Package-Catalog für Swift ist. Einfach
alles zusammen Package-Catalog.com.
Catalog ohne UE.
Und
das Problem ist, die Seite ist
unglaublich langsam, also deren Frontend
JavaScript ist beeindruckend
krass, aber es
nutzt halt nette Ajax-APIs
im Hintergrund und ich dachte mir, ich gehe da
einfach mal daher und schreibe eine CLI,
die quasi von dort dir
Dinge suchen kann.
Ich weiß nicht, Ajax?
Ich weiß nicht, irgendwas, was
JavaScript hier Dinge im Hintergrund zieht,
aber mit einer JSON-RP spricht.
Und wenn du halt hier in die Suche was eingibst
und bevor die Detailseite zu einem Package geladen hat,
dauert manchmal gefühlt echt Jahre.
Das ist aber, weil sie das erst darstellen,
wenn es komplett gerendert wurde.
Das ist ja auf einmal aufgepoppt.
Ja, aber ich meine, die rufen die Daten halt auch ab
und die rendern das Markdown
dann nochmal und also die Seite
ist dreckig langsam und das finde ich
eklig und ich wollte benutzen.
Aber witzigerweise ist
Creates.io mittlerweile auch
so. Ich klicke hier auf eine Seite
und dann darf ich mir eine halbe Sekunde lang
Loading... angucken, bis dann auf einmal
komplett fertig so eine Unterseite aufpoppt.
Wie dem auch sei, ich will auch nicht unbedingt
auf einer Webseite suchen. Ich wollte es schön
kompakt und klein halten und da bot sich die
CLI halt wunderbar an. Und in anderen Sprachen
gibt es auch. Du kannst auch mit NPM Dinge suchen.
Das geht wunderbar schön und schnell. Das sollte eigentlich
ein Feature von deinem Paketmanager sein. Genau.
Und deswegen habe ich dafür ein Tool gebaut.
Und es war anfangs gedacht als
Zieht von diversen Quellen.
Da habe ich PackageCadalog.com reingenommen
und die Seite Libraries.io,
was diese schöne
Sprach-agnostische,
Package-Manager, Dependency-Manager-
agnostische. Die Seite, die
dich glauben macht, dass es zehnmal mehr Go-Prakete
als alle anderen Sprachen zusammen gibt.
Jedenfalls
habe ich die beiden Quellen reingezogen und wollte
da halt Packages ausziehen
und dir die anzeigen lassen und dann wollte ich es
eigentlich soweit noch machen, dass du da quasi
Remind-to sagen kannst, hier, adde
mal dieses Package und dann fügt es das deiner Manifest-Datei
hinzu und dann kann der Switch-Package-Manager
Nachdem ich ein bisschen rumgespielt hatte mit den Sachen, ist mir auch gefallen, dass die Datenbasis von Libraries.io unglaublich, sagen wir mal, heterogen ist.
Die haben viele Packages doppelt drin, teilweise unter verschiedenen Namen, oft mit kaputten URLs.
Und das habe ich dann doch mal wieder fallen lassen.
Ich habe nur Package-Catalog.com genommen, habe das damit gebastelt, das Tool, habe erstmal noch fallen lassen, dass du das in deine Package-Finalfest mit reinziehen kannst.
Du kannst also nur suchen und du kannst sagen, ich möchte mehr Infos zu einem Package und du kannst sagen, ich möchte das hinzufügen.
Und dann kopiert er dir das nötige für deine Package-Manifest-Datei in die Clipboard.
Und das ist erstmal ganz nett.
Ich habe versucht ein bisschen Feedback zu bekommen.
Und habe gesagt bekommen, dass er doch keine Sau Package-Catalog.com nutzt.
Und die haben halt, also das stimmt ja auch, niemand kennt die Seite.
Und die haben halt so oder so nie alle Packages.
Weil die können auch nur GitHub crawlen.
Aber es gibt auch keine offizielle, das sind alle Surfpakete.
Nein, gibt es nicht.
Deswegen bin ich gerade dabei, das Tool nochmal neu zu machen.
Das heißt übrigens Apodide ist
lateinisch für die Familie der
Swifts. Und es lässt
sich schön kürzen auf
ein Command-Eintool namens
Apo. Und kannst einfach Apo Search
Suchbegriff eingeben oder Apo Info
Suchbegriff oder Apo Add
Suchbegriff. Aber es ist eine schöne
Abkürzung, die noch nicht so...
Also als Command-Eintool, APO,
ist es halt was, was uns selten irgendwo... Genau.
Das fand ich echt schön. Das klang
so unbefleckt. Wenn ich
Apo eingebe und
TapTap mache, kriege ich echt sonst nichts angeboten.
Spannend.
Genau, ich habe es
wie gesagt mal zusammengeschrieben,
läuft auch soweit,
benutzt halt die Datenquelle von
Package Catalog. Das Problem ist bloß,
Package Catalog, gerade für so Info-Requests
ist es ein bisschen
schwierig.
Du musst da Case-Sensitive
tatsächlich bleiben und
das macht es halt so unglaublich eklig
vom Interface her für den Nutzer zu searchen.
Deswegen musst du es immer zwei Requests abschicken.
Einmal die Suche und dann nimmt das das erste Suchresultat
und holt dir dazu die Infos wieder raus.
Und das ist halt ein bisschen doof,
weil es dadurch auch wieder echt langsam wird.
Schreibst du das mit Promises?
Ja, tatsächlich. Das ist Promises-basiert.
Aber du musst die halt nacheinander abschicken an der Stelle.
Du musst Promise Kit intern.
Auch eine coole Swift-Library.
Nice.
Du kannst auch über Homebook schon installieren,
zumindest über meinen Tab.
Du hast kein Syntaxer-Leiting in deinen Code-Beispielen.
Ja, was soll ich denn für Syntaxer-Leiting nutzen?
Das ist, ja, aber dann macht er dir das kaputt,
weil das sind mal im Innen dazwischen
und sonst was. Ich hatte
Shell-Highlighting drin, aber das sah halt doof aus.
Das ist halt kein Code, der hier ist,
sondern das ist Shell-Interaction.
Aber stimmt, dass die sowas nicht haben, ist krass.
Apu-Search,
RX-Swift und dann kriegst du
die Ergebnisse. Genau.
Das ist cool, das kannst du noch ein bisschen farbiger machen.
Der Output ist teilweise farbig,
hier habe ich es mal nur bold belassen und
manche Sachen unterstrichen.
Also wenn du dir den Output von sowas wie...
Da ist es halt grün.
Achso, wenn du jetzt den Output von so einem Tool wie
Jaurt anguckst.
Jaurt. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da jetzt ein Bild finde.
Der ist halt sehr brun, das stimmt.
Du hast halt hier so Sachen stehen wie erst den Namespace,
in dem es vorkommt, dann Slash,
den tatsächlichen Namen und dann die Versionsnummer.
Das könnte man irgendwie farbig trennen bei Jaurt.
Wenn ich da Bilder von finde.
Was finde ich?
Bilder von Joghurt.
Ja, da, da, da.
Da unten noch besser.
Genau, aber da hast du hier zum Beispiel das Repo in einer anderen Farbe und in einer Version und bei Updates sehe ich ja noch das Diff zwischen der alten und der neuen Version in einer unterschiedlichen Farbe.
Das ist eigentlich ganz schick.
Dann könntest du noch ein gutes Stück bunter machen, das stimmt.
Nee, aber was mir dann gesagt wurde als Feedback ist doch, Package-Catalog ist doch nur ein Subside der Swift-Packages.
Genau.
Und ich habe da mal ein bisschen umgesucht.
Das war auch ursprünglich meine Idee, nicht ursprünglich die Idee, aber die Idee hatte ich dann zwischenzeitlich auch schon mal gehabt.
Warum denn ich einfach die GitHub-Suche bemühen?
habe die Idee aber nochmal verworfen gehabt,
weil du dafür
ziemlich viele Requests an die GitHub
API abschicken musst.
Du könntest das selber irgendwo cachen oder sowas.
Aber das wirst du halt auch nicht. Das Schönste wäre halt die Homebrew,
einfach ein Git-Repo mit dem Listing, aber das müssen
Leute auch nutzen. Das muss irgendwie aktuell sein.
Die brauchen halt wirklich einen zentralen Katalog.
Die brauchen halt sowas wie NPM
oder Crate.io.
Müsst es für sowas mal geben.
Wäre schön.
Gibt es auch, benutzt es bloß keine Sache.
Bei Packet-Katalog,
trägt sich ja auch offenbar niemand selber ein.
Die tragen das hier zusammen.
Du kannst Packages submitten. Ganz oben ist ein Submit-Link.
Die wollen dann einfach
eine GitHub-URL von dir haben.
Das Problem, was sie halt da machen,
ist, die crawlen alle Packages, die sie kennen,
regelmäßig, hinden sie mal die GitHub-API,
holen sie aktuelle Versionen, die aktuelle Readme und so weiter.
Und wenn du einmal,
so glaube ich zumindest, es verstanden zu haben,
wenn du ein Package hier drin hast, dann crawlen sie auch
die Autoren regelmäßig nach neuen Repos,
schauen, ob das Swift-Repos sind, schauen,
ob die eine Package-Swift haben und wenn ja, dann fügen sie
die auch gleich hinzu. Also die machen das schon
clever, finde ich. Aber sie haben halt
so oder so, können sie nicht alles haben,
weil das geht einfach nicht anders.
Eigentlich, was so ein bisschen der
Downfall von
Package-Catalog.com ist,
dass der Name nicht
sexy ist. Und da steht auch noch IBM davor.
Das klingt zu sehr nach Corporate.
Ja, das ist auch eklig.
Was cool wäre, und ich setze dir jetzt ein Floh ins Ohr,
was cool wäre,
Apolidee
.io als zentrales
Package-Management-System
als Package-Registry
für Swift.
Ja, aber am liebsten wäre es mir fast, wenn
Apple da auf Swift.org irgendwie was
Packages.swift.org oder Catalog.swift.org
draus machen würde und das wäre einfach
schön sauber. Ja, eigentlich liegt das...
Ihr seid froh, dass das Package-Catalog.com
vorher hieß, dass irgendwie
irgendwas, Prefix.bluemix.net
slash irgendwas, slash irgendwas, slash irgendwas
und da lief die Seite eine Weile.
Die haben wahrscheinlich dann irgendwann
endlich mal die Erlaubnis von ihrem Management bekommen,
sich mal eine Domain zu registrieren.
Aber bitte hier nicht so ein Hipster-Scheiß.
Mach bitte einen Namen, der auch sinnvoll ist.
Sowas wie Package-Katalog. Aber es ist halt trotzdem IBM.
Die könnten halt auch Dinge rausfliegen lassen.
Zum Beispiel mit Ketora-Konkurrenz.
Ja, deswegen sollte das eigentlich in der Hand
von den Leuten sein, die die Sprache machen.
Nee, eigentlich auch nicht. Warte mal, also bei
Ruby, Ruby-James ist
nicht in der Hand der Leute, die die Sprache machen.
Die unterstützen,
die werden so ein bisschen unterstützt
von einer anderen Community noch, aber
das ist unabhängig voneinander. NPM
ist auch unabhängig von Node
komplett.
Theoretisch könnte man
Swift-Pakete in NPM packen. Ich habe neulich
mal geguckt, wie man Go-Pakete in NPM packt.
Gibt es auch schon.
Und
gut, bei Rust
ist es nur der Fall, dass das alles aus einer Hand
kommt, was aber an der Stelle auch in Ordnung ist, weil
es ist alles aus der Hand von
so einer Organisation wie Marzella kommt.
Bei Swift wäre es fast ein bisschen
bedenklich, wenn es so ein zentrales Package-Rudges
von Apple gebe. Das fühlt sich falsch an.
Es fühlt sich echt falsch an.
An der anderen Seite ist es aber das, wo du dann am ehesten
Discoverability hast und wo du
am wenigsten Probleme hast, Leute wiederzufinden.
Oder Pakete zu finden, weil sowas wie
Libraries.io, da gucke ich nie hin.
Nee, warum auch?
Der Name ist cool,
der Gedanke dahinter ist auch cool, aber du findest halt
seltsames Zeugs. Also gerade
diese Aussage, das wollte ich
vorhin. Gerade auf Libraries.io kannst du
beispielsweise mal nach MBM suchen
und die Sprache eingrenzen. Wenn du auf MBM suchst
einkrenzt, dann findest du tatsächlich die Dinger
in Swift geschrieben, die im NPM gepublished sind.
Echt, ja. Sehr witzig. Aber gut,
die haben ja echt ganz viel drin,
Libraries.io, die haben GoRubyGems,
NPM, PyP,
Packages, weiß ich gar nicht, was das ist,
Maven sogar,
WordPress-Pakete, CocoaPods,
Kran, es sind R-Projekte,
Meteor, C-Span,
C-Span ist der Fernsehsender,
C-Pan meinst du.
C-Pan, ja klar, C-Span.
Pub hab ich auch noch nie gehört,
aber dem Bild nach zu urteilen, sind das Dart-Pakete.
Elm, Julia.
Das muss ich alle vorlesen.
Aber ja, die haben quasi alles, wo man so Dependency sehr bezieht.
Aber hier steht auch Swift PM.
Ja, ich habe halt nicht rausgefunden, wo die die herziehen.
Ich glaube, die crawlen auch bloß GitHub.
Ich wüsste halt nicht, wo die herziehen, weil du kriegst von denen auch nur eine GitHub.
Und hier siehst du schon, die haben so kaputte URLs
wie github.com slash github.com
slash elmofire slash elmofire.
Was soll denn das?
Warum steht da noch ein extra github.com vor?
Das sind sicherlich alle kaputt, die man hier sieht.
oder github.com slash git at github.com
Oh Mann!
Aber das unten scheint nicht kaputt zu sein.
github.com slash ibm.com slash github.com
Ja, ja.
Was mir gerade noch eingefallen ist,
ist
LibQIO
oder
Lib...
Nee, Quatsch. Wie hieß das?
Include
mit Q.
Include.org mit Q statt C.
Das sind dann Qt-Pakete.
schön
so, aber aufgrund der Ladezeit
zu urteilen, ist die
Zeit auch vielleicht schon gar nicht mehr da
ne, ähm
genau, ähm
ja, ähm
Apuride, angucken
genau, es ist halt wie gesagt
nicht allzu nützlich im aktuellen Zeitpunkt
kann ich schon über Brew studieren?
ja, wie gesagt, du kannst einfach mal
Brewtap, Kianco, slash
Tap, slash Formule
wahrscheinlich
slash Formular
slash Tab klappt glaube ich auch,
die Alias ist einfach alles untereinander
durch.
So kannst du dir irgendwo
Schwalbe installieren.
Ah, weiß.
Nee, aber zurück zu der Problematik,
dass ich, wenn ich die GitHub-Suche
direkt ansprechen würde, da
unglaublich viele Anfragen machen
müsste. Was würdest du da anfragen?
Du würdest, gib mir mal alle Pakete, die zu
90% aus Swift bestehen
und eine Swift,
wie heißt die,
Package-Swift beinhalten.
Dafür müsste ich für jedes Suchresultat zumindest noch einmal
den Request absetzen und das
skatiert halt schon nicht mehr. Dann brauchst du noch viel länger,
als das, was ich aktuell mache.
Es gibt, glaube ich, da habe ich auch mal mal,
wo war das, in Changelog drüber gehört,
es gibt noch so eine andere API.
GraphQL, das ist genau die Überleitung,
die ich jetzt machen wollte.
Genau, und das habe ich dann eben gestern
entdeckt. Von der Changelog-Folge
weiß ich noch, dass die existiert.
Ich habe die Chunks endlich mal genutzt, um damit
rumzuspielen und ich glaube, ich habe mich gestern
in GraphQL verliebt.
Das ist unglaublich geil.
Also das ist quasi einfach nur ein Endpoint
und an den schickst du eine Query,
was irgendwie eine Structured
Query ist, wo du sagst, quasi hier,
das ist die Infos, die ich haben möchte
und die GitHub-API füllt dir das
quasi nur aus, quasi mit den Daten,
die sie haben und schickt es dir zurück.
Die machen quasi Pattern-Matching drauf.
Aber ja,
die füllen dir einfach deine Struktur aus. Du sagst, ich möchte diese Struktur
an Daten und du kriegst diese Daten zurück.
Und das ist unglaublich fancy, in dem Sinne von
einerseits, du kriegst nur die Daten,
die du haben möchtest,
du kriegst nicht mehr und du
spammst nicht den Nutzer mit unerhörtlich vielen Daten voll.
Das Ganze ist typisiert,
sprich, du kannst nicht aus Versehen irgendwo,
keine Ahnung, String reinspeisen, wo du eigentlich
Parameter und Integer erwartest,
da sind solche Attribute überall noch mit dran.
Und du kriegst das alles in einem Request.
Und somit kann ich einen Request an GitHub schicken,
von wegen, such mal bitte nach diesem Suchstring
alle SwiftLine-Repos durch.
Und ich möchte bitte mit, du kannst leider nicht filtern
im GraphQL, das ist halt nicht wirklich eine Query Language,
das ist meine Art Structure Language,
aber ich kann mir zumindest die Git-Object-ID
von der Package-Swift mitgeben lassen.
Du musst dann kleinzeitig nochmal die filtern, die einfach keine haben,
die schmeiß ich dann wieder weg. Und dann kannst du die Datei quasi
direkt runterladen. Muss ich ja nicht mal.
Das reicht mir ja schon, dass die existent ist.
Ja, ich meine um so
Metadaten-Version und Autor.
Die liegen ja mit einem GitHub-Buch schon mit dran, die gibt mir die GitHub-API
ja auch schon mit. Ja, nicht unbedingt.
Also ich habe in meinem Dings, habe ich ja Pakete
eventuell drin, wo ich andere Leute als Autoren mit
eingegeben habe, weil die mir Pull-Requests geschickt haben.
Wie meinst du als Autoren mit drinstehen?
Nein, in deinem Meta-Datenprojekt
Package-Swift, Package-Json,
Tommel, was weiß ich,
hast du immer eine Autorenliste drinstehen.
Okay.
Die nicht unbedingt mit den Autoren
auf dem Git-Repo übereinstimmen müssen.
Okay, Thomas macht Zwift nicht.
So was steht im Package-Manifest nicht drin.
Okay.
Vielleicht für die Zukunft was, aber ich weiß nicht,
ob das...
bei Airverse ist es ja so, damit du es auf
CFO anzeigen kannst. Genau, bei NPM
ist es ja auch. So was hat es auch nicht.
Ja, gut, okay.
Eigentlich krass.
Das ist so eine Checkliste.
Ich mache eine neue Programmiersprache. Was brauchst
du alles? Du brauchst halt
irgendwie einen Compiler, da
denken die Leute dran. Das ist das Erste, was du machst.
Dann brauchst du eine Standardbibliothek, da denken die Leute
auch dran. Dann brauchst du aber heutzutage
einen Paketmanager, da denken die Leute nicht immer dran.
Witzigerweise
Jahren schon gemacht und
Swift hat das vergessen bis jetzt mal eben.
Der Package Manager ist ja da. Swift Package Manager
existiert, der ist auch ziemlich mächtig mittlerweile
mit Swift 4. Aber zu einem Package Manager
gehört dann halt auch so eine Art
Package Registry. Muss die halt
dazugehören? Das ist halt die Frage. Swift versucht
es halt so dezentral zu machen, dass du halt ein Git Repo
einfach reinlegst. Aber das Gap-University
ist halt nicht da. Das ist das eine, was halt lag.
Ein Git Repository kann ich bei NPM und
bei Cargo auch mit reinschreiben.
Ja.
Aber wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel
offizielle
Library zum Ansprechen meiner
bestimmten API haben möchte,
dann möchte ich nicht der 35.
Treffer auf GitHub sein oder
mir das auf GitHub als
Org registrieren
müssen dafür. Du musst halt die Nutzer haben.
Du musst die Leute das
Webost da haben, dass Leute das Ding vor allem nutzen
und viele Installationen haben.
Das kannst du halt aggregieren in Informationen.
Das ist schon da.
Aber die GitHub API gibt mir halt, ich habe dann diese Query
formuliert, die sieht so hier aus.
wo all die Informationen drinstecken, die ich
haben möchte. Ich gebe mir quasi hier
einen Link dazu.
Das ist jetzt quasi dein Query?
Das ist die Query, die ich an
api.github.com slash GraphQL schicke.
Ein Fall als Post Request.
Ist das JSON?
Das ist kein JSON.
Das sieht bloß ein bisschen so aus.
Ich habe hier so einzelne
ich kriege hier Repositories
hier mit drin und ich kann dir sagen, welche
Informationen von dem Repo interessieren mich. Ich kann mir
auch noch rausholen, die Description,
die URL,
die License hat ja GitHub,
das ist mega nice und dann kriege ich diese Daten raus.
Ich fand das einfach großartig und habe dann
zufällig mit dir... Das ist der offizielle GraphQL-Adito,
den du hast? Das ist GraphIQL,
das ist einfach ein Client,
an dem du das immer nochmal rumspielen kannst.
Das ist super, also wenn ich überlege,
wie ich da gesessen habe,
für mich ist es kein Verlust, ich habe rumgespielt
und Spaß gehabt, aber für die Firma,
für die ich arbeite, ist da halt Arbeitszeit
drauf gegangen, dass ich irgendwie
REST API, wo du entweder
über Queries oder über
JSON hinschickst, dann bestimmte Anfragen
rauskriegst, dich dann mit so einem Tool
wie Insomnia oder wie heißen die Alternativen dazu?
Wir haben ein paar
REST Endpoints
Abfrage, um bestimmte Daten zu aggregieren.
Wenn ich mir das da angucke,
dann sagst du, hier bitte füll das mal für mich aus.
Das ist einfach so simpel. Es ist
wunderschön. Wie gesagt, es fehlen ein paar Möglichkeiten,
die du halt von der Query Language erwartest.
Du könntest sagen, gib mal bitte alle Repos,
wo das so und so ist, also so eine Wear-Filter,
oder einen Like-Filter via SQL.
Sowas kann das nicht.
Aber so könntest du es serverseitig implementieren.
Die serverseitige Information von GraphQL
ist ein bisschen interessanter.
Da habe ich es, wie gesagt, gestern ein bisschen eingelesen,
weil ich tatsächlich mit Johannes,
meinem Co-Maintainer vom Parken-PD-Projekt,
der mit dabei saß, als ich gestern hier saß
und das erstmalig damit rumgespielt habe,
unterhalten habe, das ist ja mega geil,
weil wir das für unsere Park-API auch mit nutzen würden.
Jeder API sollte GraphQL quasi anbieten.
Es ist richtig.
Du hast, wenn du halt nicht nur einen Client,
einen Nutzer deiner API hast,
dann haben die alle unterschiedliche Anforderungen.
Die wollen alle unterschiedliche Daten haben. Und wenn sich jemand
einen Statusmonitor anzeigt, wo
alle Parkplätze in Dresden anzeigt, dann müssen wir
den doch nicht mit Koordinateninfos spammen. Die braucht
er gar nicht für jeden Parkplatz.
Und dann kann er die Informationen holen, die er haben möchte.
Und mit den Informationen gucken, die er haben
möchte. Die Überlegung ist, wo dann
die meiste Arbeit passiert. Wenn ich jetzt momentan
einfach ein REST-Interface anbiete, wo ich zwar irgendwie
über mehrere Anfragen alles mögliche anbiete
und ich jemandem irgendwie
eine krasse API anbiete, wo ich dem sage,
schick mir mal eine Liste von Keys,
die du haben möchtest oder sowas.
Und der muss aber trotzdem hinterher Sachen verknüpfen
und umformen bei sich.
Na klar, es könnte sein,
dass die Query ein bisschen komplexer,
serverseitig wird zum Auswerten.
Bei dem hier kann es halt passieren,
dass ich der API in einen Query schicke,
wo die halt relativ viel Zeit verbrennt,
weil das ist halt ein komplexes, superkomplexes Query.
Kann sehr gut sein.
GitHub geht damit tatsächlich sehr interessant.
Und ganz kurz dazu,
wenn du für dich als Client
ist das, wo du am längsten drauf wartest,
ist der Network Call, ohne Frage.
Und da ist ein Network Call zu haben,
bedeutend flinker, immer, als drei Network Calls,
die halt einfacher zu berechnen sind,
also serviseitig, was du da für Daten haben möchtest.
Was GitHub macht
bei dem GraphQL Endpoint,
bei dem klassischen Rest Endpoint ist es so,
du darfst 5000 Requests pro Stunde
schicken, wenn du einen OAuth Key
mitschickst. Also bei GraphQL
schickst du den OAuth Key immer mit. Du hast immer noch
theoretisch das Limit der 5000
Requests pro Stunde.
Sie machen das auch ein bisschen anders.
das sind nicht 5000 Requests, sondern du hast
so eine Art Cost, die die dir berechnen für die Query.
Aufgrund ein paar
Sachen. Und die Queries, die ich bisher
abschicke, ich kann mir die
Kosten mit ausgeben lassen, das ist auch bloß ein Parameter,
was ich mir abmöchte. Die haben alle
eine Kosten von 1 und ich habe meine
5. Komplexität deiner Anfrage.
Wenn ich jetzt eine Anfrage
in der Sprache erlauben würde, wo ich sage,
join mir mal über mehrere Tables oder sowas,
dann wird die Kosten wahrscheinlich ganz schnell
hochgehen. Na klar, aber das ist auch ein super
anders den GitHub erfährt, dass sie quasi diese
Kosten berechnen, diese Komplexität und einfach das
Budget an der Komplexität halt festmachen.
Du hast da 5000 Punkte, die du
pro Stunde verbraten darfst und selbst,
ich dachte, ich habe hier vielleicht schon mehr als einen verbrannt,
aber nee, das ist auch nur sehr simpel.
Zählt als Cost 1.
Ist unglaublich cool.
Aber GraphQL ist fancy.
Also zusammen kann ich genau das umbauen.
Und ich habe vorhin schon mal angefangen, ich weiß wahrscheinlich, bis die Folge
raus ist, nutzt Apoli denn nicht mehr
PackageCatalog.com, sondern
die GitHub-API direkt, finde ich mega cool.
Ja, super nice.
Ja, da frage ich mich jetzt natürlich,
gibt es dann demnächst keine REST-Interfaces
mehr, REST-APIs mehr, sondern nur noch
GraphQL-APIs, weil das sinnvoller und spannender
ist? Also, kleinzeitig ist
es sehr angenehm. Du musst halt vielleicht,
je nachdem, was dir den Client für Anfragen schickt,
kann natürlich das klassische REST-Interface auch
immer noch einfacher sein in der
Nutzung und
zum Deserialisieren und Serialisieren
von Requests und Responses.
Aber es
hängt ja davon ab, es gibt wenig
GraphQL-APIs, die
da draußen, die halt gerade so viel genutzt werden.
Viele Sachen heißen auch einfach nur
irgendwas mit Graphs. Facebook hat eine Graph-API,
das hat nichts mit GraphQL zu tun. Die haben aber auch
eine GraphQL-API,
aber die ist nur intern, wird von allen Clients benutzt
und die ist nicht nach außen offen. Die kannst du nicht
für andere Anfragen nutzen.
Ansonsten kenne ich jetzt
spezifisch nur die von GitHub. Aber wie gesagt,
ich setze mich seit gestern mit GraphQL auseinander.
Ja, wir kriegen bestimmt von unseren
Hörern noch ganz viele Tipps geschickt.
Mir fallen jetzt auch gerade so Ideen ein, zum Beispiel
in Rust gibt es ja dieses Serda
Library, wo du deine
Typen in bestimmte andere Formate
serialisieren kannst und dann wäre es eigentlich cool,
wenn du deine Datenstruktur so wie
sie ist in eine
GraphQL-Abfrage, das ist ja auch bloß
eine strukturierte Datenstruktur hier, oder?
Du schickst dir einen Datenstruktur zum Server und der gibt dir
Du sagst einfach, das ist mein Typ,
da schreibe ich Serialize davor
und die Serialize, dann
sag ich, schmeiß es mal in die
API so und so, die GraphQL
rein oder
Muss ich ja gar nicht, weil ich müsste ein bisschen Typen
einmal beschrieben haben und angeben und dann fällt das
raus.
Dann musst du bestimmt irgendwelche Felder vorausfüllen,
damit du halt bestimmte
Kriterien filtern kannst.
Es gibt noch so ein schönes
GraphQL-IOS-Framework,
wenn du kleinzeitig
in deiner iOS-App mit GraphQL arbeiten
möchtest, wo du deine GraphQL-Type-Definitions
mit hinlegst und der baut dir da einfach
automatisch schon schöne Typen draus und du kannst einfach
synchronativ dann darauf arbeiten,
dass das echt nice, also in der
Chair. Natürlich ein bisschen mehr Overhead, klar.
Also eine Rest-Up, die halt auch was schick ist, im Sinne von
hey, da ist ein Endpoint, ich schicke ihn einfach hin
und passt. Ja, eigentlich
ist es nicht unbedingt einfacher, weil
die
Sprache, die du mit dem Endpoint sprechen kannst, ist ja
dadurch, dass er einfacher ist,
umständlicher. Ich muss den ja,
das Einzige, was ich sagen kann, ist hier
Pfad und dann vielleicht so ein paar
Key-Vail-Paare als Query.
Wenn ich hier dem eine komplexere
Struktur schicken kann, eine
verschachtelte Struktur, dann
kriege ich bestimmt
ein bisschen mehr. Man kann mit
REST APIs wahrscheinlich sowas schon einigermaßen
annähern, aber ein richtig geil
ist noch nicht. Das andere Schöne an einem
GraphQL Endpoint, an einem Standardskonform,
soweit ich das verstanden habe,
ist, dass er quasi Self-Documenting ist,
weil ein Get-Request
auf den GraphQL Root Endpoint
oder quasi den GraphQL Endpoint, gibt dir einfach
die komplette Speck aus, was das Ding kann, was da
alles drin steckt und du kriegst auch in der
Response quasi immer das, was du haben möchtest,
kriegst du ja auch nicht wie in manchen anderen
Westendpoints, wo du mal den Key drin hast, mal nicht,
wenn der Null ist, da wird der ganze Key einfach
ummittelt und du musst damit kleinzeitig zurechtkommen, sondern wenn du den Key
haben willst, dann kriegst du den auch, aber wenn da keine Werte sind,
dann ist da halt ein Null drin oder was auch immer.
Ich habe jetzt etwas anfrage, was quasi der Speck
überhaupt nicht entspricht. Da kriegst du einen Error.
Und dadurch, dass das halt auch typisiert
ist, kannst du halt auch, wenn du zum Beispiel hier eine, ich nenne
es mal eine Funktion, weil es aussieht wie eine Funktion, aber es ist ja quasi
Attribute an was dran, wie zum Beispiel
an diesem Search-Dings hier in meiner Query mit drin,
da will ich hier einen Type
und sogar Auto-Completion. Das kann
ein Issue-Repository oder ein User sein. Und wenn ich da was reinchecke,
was das nicht ist, dann wirft mir das das direkt
um die Ohren und sagt,
nee, das passt so nicht.
Ja, die
Completion ist wirklich ein bisschen kaputt.
Und kriegt dann einen Error eben raus. Sagen wir mal,
ich lasse hier mal das Impository, das Y-Street
am Ende weg. Sagt er mir, hey, das ist ein Error.
Kommt auch standardkonform hier raus.
Und der Error hat ein Message.
Das Ergebnis ist jetzt JSON.
Ich kriege hier jetzt JSON zurück. Wahrscheinlich ist das
auch wie du möchtest.
Und sicherlich kannst du da auch einfach klassisch
andere Header mitschicken. Ich will jetzt bitte XML,
dann kriegst du jetzt XML oder ich will jetzt irgendwas sonst was haben.
Okay, dann ist, ich hab mir die Speck von
JSON-API nie so richtig angeguckt, aber
eventuell gibt's auch
REST-APIs, die sich an das hier
doller annähern, wo du sagen kannst, ich schick dir
mal ein strukturiertes Objekt mit ein paar Lücken
und du füllst mir die bitte aus. Gibt's
auch schon anderswo. Es gibt ja auch dieses
Hypermedia, obwohl ich das nie komplett verstanden
hab, was genau das sein soll.
Das ist ein ultra-komplexes JSON-Konstrukt,
was du zurückkriegst, wo du gleich mit sehen kannst,
was für Objekte damit verknüpft sind mit Links,
wo du die bekommst, unter welchen Endpoints.
Da kannst du halt ganz generische Clients schreiben,
die mit jedem Hypermedia-Endpoint laufen
und kannst dann halt deine Daten da rausziehen.
Mega komisch.
Also zum Beispiel die REST API von Atlassian
sieht so aus, dass du bestimmte einfache Endpunkte hast,
wo du sagst, gib mal.
Und dann kriegst du halt einen relativ kleinen Block,
entweder JSON oder XML raus.
Und du hast aber am Anfang von jedem Block
noch so ein Expand-Key.
Da steht dann eine Liste von Sachen drin,
die da unten drunter vorkommen.
Und wenn ich dann in einem Query Expand
und dann einen von diesen Keys angebe,
dann kriege ich da noch mehr Daten ausgefüllt.
Und die können teilweise rekursiv weitere Sachen expanden.
Das heißt, ich kann da,
wenn ich jetzt nur sowas hier abfrage,
kann ich sagen,
expand repositories.user.name
und dann kriege ich halt in diesem Unterpunkt
mehr Details drin.
Aber es ist halt eine ganz andere Philosophie,
da ranzugehen.
wie gesagt, ich finde das cool und
zum Zeitpunkt des Hören wird hoffentlich Apolid
schon die GitHub
API nutzen und dann kannst du da einfach die suchen.
Das ist schneller, weil GitHub einfach
bedeutet schneller Antwort als der IBM-Server
und vor allem, weil es mal ein Request ist
und ich habe bedeutend mehr Daten und kann den Output
noch ein bisschen hübscher machen und erweitern
mit, was da noch mit drin steckt.
Ja, super geil. Auf jeden Fall.
Das einzige, was nochmal auf Apolid
zurückzukommen, der noch fehlt, ist, das wollte ich noch
weiter anschauen, wie genau ich das mache.
ich wollte ja eigentlich, dass du ein Package
direkt in deiner Package.swift hinzufügen kannst.
Aber dadurch, dass die Package.swift
ja einfach wirklich arbitraierer
Swift-Code sein kann. Das heißt, es wird
sogar ausgeführt? Das wird kompiliert und ausgeführt.
Aber gibt es nicht ein
minimales Subset von Package.swift?
Ich würde sagen,
99,9% aller Package.swifts entsprechen
einfach dem Standardformat, wenn du das Swift Package.init
ausführst. Aber
ich hatte einfach noch keinen
sauberen Ansatz, wie ich da was reinschreibe.
Und das muss ich mir eben noch einfallen lassen.
Du hast doch hier eine Dependencies-List.
Ja, genau.
Wenn die wirklich so da ist, dann kannst du die einfach
augmenten. Das kannst du vielleicht
irgendwie mit diesem
Ja, das war die Idee, aber das wird vielleicht ein bisschen
zu hardcore dann.
Ja, das fällt mir halt auf.
Also bei NPM ist es
gang und gäbe, dass du einfach über die Kommandozeile
Dependencies hinzufügst. Aber sowas gibt es zum Beispiel
auch für Rust.
Das passt dir einmal deine
Cargo-Tommel, schreibt dann
an der einen Stelle halt ein Key dazu und dann
printet es dir eine Cargotumbe
wieder raus, die dann halt komplett anders aussieht,
weil du es halt von Anfang an eigentlich handgeschrieben hast.
Achso, das war meine Befürchtung, dass wenn ich
das zum Beispiel in den AST von meiner Package mit Parse
oder was in Zufüge an einer bestimmten Stelle wieder
ausgeben, dass die halt einfach
nicht mehr dem entspricht, was der Nutzer vorher hatte, sondern
quasi so, wie ich sie als sinnvoll befinde.
Naja, was du noch anders machen kannst, ist, dass du dir von dem
Parse halt dann die
Code Points geben lässt, das heißt, du sagst
parse das mal, aber sag mir mal einfach
bloß, an welcher Stelle der Eintrag Dependencies
steht. Und dann
gib mir mal eine Zeilennummer von wo bis wo
und dann fügst du halt einfach in der letzten Zeile
hart, ohne dass du parsen, noch eine Zeile hinzu.
Und kannst du vielleicht noch parsen, wie die
Indentation ist, um dann davon abzuleiten.
Das wäre eine Idee. Apropos
ableiten, lass uns mal umleiten.
Wir haben hier noch ein Thema
auf unserer Agenda stehen. Ja, wir haben
noch eins übrigens, das haben wir vorher übersprungen.
Und zwar geht es da um
IO als TLD,
wo jemand einen witzigen Angriff gefahren hat.
das habe ich gerade offen gehabt, ja
und zwar, man kann
alle IO-URLs
nicht mehr, aber man konnte
alle IO-Domains
registrieren und
der Registrar hat da keine Ausnahmen gemacht
für die Standard-DNS
Server
und das ist halt ein bisschen eklig
gewesen.
Er hat keine
Ausnahmen für die Standard-Registrar.
Es gibt so ein paar Standard-DNS-Adressen, die du
erwartest auf einer TLD, soweit ich weiß.
nick.io oder sowas. Das ist so eine
Standardseite, wo du den Registrar erwartest
zu finden, aber
ich kenne mich da jetzt nicht so im Detail
aus, als dass ich wüsste, wie die genau
heißen, wenn ich den Blog mal lesen. Wer
verwaltet denn IO-Domains? Indischer
Ozean, Inselgruppe,
IO halt.
Irgendwas im Indischen Ozean.
Ist auch eine Nation. Oder ein Teil
einer Nation. Ja, so wie Tuvalu, die
wahrscheinlich die Hälfte ihres Landeseinkommens
damit machen, TV-Domains zu verkaufen.
Obwohl das TV-Domains sind nicht mehr hip.
Ja.
Es kommt ja kein Mensch mehr Fernsehen heutzutage.
Oder RS für die Wrestler, das ist ja auch Serbien.
Die sind schon eine Feuerwehr.
IO ist auch nicht billig, leider.
Du hast Kilian-IO, ne?
Ich habe Kilian-IO und ich habe hier wieder auch eine Anfrage von irgendeinem Herr Kilian
oder einem mit Vornamen Kilian, der die von mir kaufen möchte,
aber ich will die nicht hergeben.
Außerdem ist das meine Standard-Mail-Adresse.
Die Domain kostet mich, ich glaube, 30, 40 Dollar im Jahr,
was ziemlich viel ist, finde ich.
aber die Anfragen, die bieten mir auch immer nur wenige hundert.
Also dafür würde ich sie eh nicht verkaufen wollen.
Ja, wenn du mal so zusammenrechnest,
was wir so im Jahr für Top-Level-Domains ausgeben.
Für Top-Level-Domains?
Nein, die TLD habe ich noch nicht.
Punkt, Kilian oder so.
Das wäre es ja als nächstes bei der ICAN-Anfragen.
Ja, aber zurück zum Angriff.
Der Typ hat diese Standard-Name-Server.
Müssten wir den Steiger mal befragen,
wie das genau funktioniert.
Standard-DNS-Server, die auf irgendwelchen TLDs laufen.
versucht zu registrieren, was eigentlich nicht machbar sein sollte
und hat gemerkt, oh, der Registrar
lässt mich hier registrieren und
was ist da jetzt los? Und dann ging plötzlich ziemlich viele
Requests an den Server von irgendwelchen Leuten, die DNS
auflösen wollten
und er hat vier von diesen, ich glaube
standardmäßig sieben, meint der,
in seinem Blogpost, Servern registriert
und hätte damit komplett DNS
halt für IO-Domains poisoning können
und das ist halt schon irgendwie ziemlich bitter, der hat das den Leuten
drauf aufmerksam gemacht von die IO-Verwalten
und die haben ihm die Domains dann wieder
abgenommen und gesperrt, dass Leute die
können, aber sowas soll doch bitte nicht einfach
möglich sein. Aber apropos Steiger
fragen, zufälligerweise ist
Steiger heute auch mit hier.
Wo kommst du denn her? Aus meiner
Premiere-Ecke. Und hackt im Hintergrund rum.
Kannst du da ein bisschen
mehr Licht drauf werfen,
wie sowas funktioniert?
Also du hast schon recht gehabt mit den
Name-Servern, die da an
well-known-addresses
reichbar sind, so ein Nick oder ein
Nock, je nachdem.
Also NUC
oder Klopf.
Information oder
KMZ.
Also Network, okay.
Und neben dem DNS
gibt es auch noch
das Whois-System,
über das man ja rauskriegt,
wer ein Domain registriert hat.
An wen muss ich mich wenden,
wo wir die Briefe des Anwalts sind,
wenn man das wegschicken muss.
Und ich nehme an,
dass es darüber ein Problem
gegeben haben könnte,
weil man halt das
Whois-System anfragt erstmal,
um rauszukriegen,
wie ist denn der Name-Server.
Das heißt, immer das über das Who-Is-Tech,
gibt es da irgendwelche anderen Sachen,
wo der DNS-Request eher hingeht?
Also auf der normalen Ebene,
also wenn ich eine normale Domain anfrage,
Second-Level-Domain,
dann läuft das ja eigentlich immer damit einher,
dass ich die Domain anfrage
und der Name-Server mir sagt,
okay, du willst den SOA-Record,
den Start-of-Authority-Record an der Stelle
und er sagt, okay, wenn du den SOA-Record anfragst,
dann schicke ich dir nochmal die Name-Server mit,
weil es ja sein kann,
dass mein Name-Server in meiner Domain liegt.
Ah, na klar. Und damit ich dann nicht in eine Endlosschleife
komme, macht er das direkt
mit. Aber auf der allerobersten
Ebene, also auf der Root-Level-Ebene,
wird der Austausch
anders betrieben. Und da könnte ich mir
vorstellen, dass es da ein paar Probleme gab.
Und die I.O.-Leute haben sich vielleicht gedacht,
wir müssen das ein bisschen hipstermäßiger aufziehen.
Das ist ja kein Hipster, wie gesagt, das ist einfach
Indische Ozean. Vielleicht hat das auch keine Ahnung.
Warum müssen wir jetzt unsere eigene
Top-Level-Domain hier verwalten? Wir haben doch so ein paar Inseln
bloß. Ja, keine Ahnung. Aber
wahrscheinlich haben die das einfach versäumt.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Es war natürlich ein bisschen bitterer Angriff,
wenn du halt quasi die kompletten DNS-Traffic da...
Das ist interessant, woher die die Adressen haben,
weil normalerweise ging es ja vorher auch,
also entweder hat es die ganze Zeit immer in einer Art Fallback funktioniert.
Sowas da völlig aus, ja.
Oder es gibt Spezialisten, die im Prinzip gesagt haben,
ja, das Nick für eine Double-Level-Domain
ist halt immer ein Nick. Double-Level-Domain.
Und da frage ich die einfach immer an.
Und dann gab es vielleicht doch bei denen sowas vorbeig.
So ein Art-Code kann aber auch böse in die Hose gehen.
Ja, natürlich.
Das gab es doch schon oft genug.
Tja.
Nee, war einfach eine witzige Sache.
Vielleicht habe ich mich so gut gestolpert und als Inhaber einer
IODomain hat mich natürlich direkt mal interessiert.
Also hier gibt es den
IODomainDNSTrustGraph,
der viel zu groß ist, um den hier
darzustellen.
Und da machst du eine Anfrage
an f.rootservice.net
und dann landest du bei
a1.nic.io
und wenn du nicht da landest, landest du bei
b1.nic.io und so weiter
sofort. Und in
dem Blogpost ist beschrieben, dass
er
NS-A1, A2,
A3.io waren unregistered und da
gingen halt die Requests bei Default direkt mit hin.
Genau, und dann stellst du da
wahrscheinlich auch eine Standardsoftware hin
und ich meine, die erste Überlegung,
was ich mich gefragt habe, war, hä, hat der
dann irgendwie so eine Art falsche Nick-Domain
aufgemacht? Aber nee, der hat einfach irgendwie
eine API mit angeboten, eine Standard-API wahrscheinlich
mit angeboten. Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass das
einfach Platzhalter war, dass
die IO-Leute gesagt haben, wenn die Last so hoch wird
oder wenn wir irgendwie mal einen ganz schlimmen
Serverausfall haben bei unserem Name-Server-System,
dann fahren wir an den Domains
oder an den Adressen,
die die Server hoch sind, registrieren die halt
oder hinterlegen die halt per Blue-Record
im Top-Level-System,
dass die dann entsprechend angefangen haben.
Es ist aber verpennt, das irgendwie zu belegen oder so.
Ja, genau.
Also hier ist ein bisschen die
Vorbeck-Kette, welche Domains
du bei so einem Registrar anfragst
und welcher Reihenfolge ist hier schön visualisiert.
und der hat halt so ein paar
rot hervorgehoben, die offenbar dann nicht
registriert waren oder die man sich
registrieren konnte.
Vorher jemand mit bösen Absichten hätte das halt gemacht.
Gab es nicht mal eine Geschichte von
einem, der mit den Inhabern, welches Land ist ein Punkt
CM?
Zumindest habe ich irgendwie mal so eine grose
Geschichte gehört, das ist jetzt alles auch
Kamerun.
Dass der irgendwie gesagt hat,
wenn hier irgendwie bei euch eine Anfrage
reinkommt und ihr
keine Domain registriert habt, dann leitet das doch einfach mal
an mich weiter, ich kümmer mich dann da drum.
Und das ist aber eine Idee, dass man, wenn einer
irgendwas.com eingibt und sich vertippt und dann
.cm eingibt, das ist halt bei dem gelandet.
Stimmt, das passiert mir auch gerne mal, dass ich einfach.cm
eingebe. Oh, stimmt.
Oh, ist ja hart.
Also,.com, der Vertipp habe ich da
gar nicht gedacht, aber da kannst du ja richtig die schönen
dazwischen schieben und mal... Ja, oder für
Phishing, man sieht nicht sofort, dass das nicht.com,
sondern.cm ist.
Aua. Ein anderer Hack,
neulich irgendwo mal drüber gegangen ist,
also es war glaube ich kein Hack, aber
war auch glaube ich auf Twitter, warum es eine schlechte
Idee wäre, Emojis als
Top-Level-Domain oder als
URL nach? Das hängt von der TLD
ab, dass das möglich ist. Ja, du hast dann zum
Beispiel, deine URL ist
hier
Padlock-Emoji
HTTPS
Richtig böse wird es halt,
wenn du einfach komplett Unicode drin hast und du
in zum Beispiel AP,
komisches L, was in sonstiger Sprache,
komisches L in sonstiger Sprache,
nee, AP, komisches L,
E.com, was halt, wenn dein Browser
so anzeigt, in Chrome zum Beispiel wie Apple.com
aussieht, hast du auch ein SSL-Sertifikat mit hinlegen,
dann wird es vom Browser als super safe angekündigt,
aber es ist halt nicht Apple.com, es ist
einfach irgendwelche anderen Huberzeichen.
Jetzt gibt es ja die Seite, tatsächlich.
Die Tatsache, dass du jetzt über Let's Encrypt jede
Domain
zertifizieren lassen kannst, ist geil.
Jetzt ist natürlich der Angriffspunkt, dass
Domain so aussieht wie die Original-Domain.
Und wenn deine
Domain ist, padlockemoji
https
und dann
.
oder http.s oder
https und dann hast du
slash und dann slash apple.com
dann hast du natürlich
einen Anklass mit der Anklass.
Wenn die Leute nicht genau hingucken.
Der Browser zeigt dir das Skim dann gar nicht mehr an
und dann sieht es ja alles valide aus.
Früher war das noch so, du konntest dir immer sicher sein,
dass du nicht gefischt hast, wenn du einfach mal genau auf die
URL-Leiste schaust, durch genaues Hinschauen
kannst du dir nicht mehr sicher sein.
Was halt auch dazu beiträgt, dass sowas wie
ein URL-Parser im Browser mit
eines der wichtigsten
Sicherheitsmerkmale ist, dass das sauber gepasst wird.
Also mein Browser zeigt mir an, welcher Teil dieser URL
jetzt hier Protokoll ist und welcher Teil
Domain ist und welcher Teil
Query ist. Das wird ein bisschen farblich
hervorgehoben, aber wenn der sich da verschluckt, weil du
irgendwas drin hast, was der nicht richtig hinkriegt.
Gab es da nicht auch mal schöne Angriffe,
die dann irgendwie die Schreibrichtung geändert haben
in der URL, um quasi ein Stück zu verbergen?
Oh Gott, das ist halt die Begründung dafür,
warum du nicht alle möglichen
Unicode-Zeichen in URLs erlauben möchtest,
sondern nur so Subsets.
Weil du zum Beispiel
Unicode-Zeichen hast, die
sagen, geh mal wieder
ein Zeichen zurück, dass ich mehrere Zeichen
übereinander schreiben kann.
Dann hast du nicht Apple, sondern zweimal
A übereinander.com
pbl.com
aus wie Apple, weil es zwei übereinander liegende A's sind.
Drei A's.
Du nimmst dieses russische Zeichen, was genauso aussieht wie ein A?
Ich habe es noch.
Safari zeigt es mir an als XN-Minus,
also so wie man halt so typische Sonderzeichendomain anzeigt.
80 AK 6AA92E.com
Und wenn du es in Chrome die Seite
aufrufst, dann steht in der URL einfach Apple.com
Wie ist die,
gab es nicht einen Namen für diese Schreibweise? Ist das Punicode?
Punicode, ja.
Genau.
Irgendwelche verrückten Domänen an.
Also Kinder, schaut immer genau in die Adressleiste,
wenn ihr Online-Packen macht.
Ja, und nutzt einen Browser, der das
richtig anzeigt. Also bei Chrome wird das
jetzt falsch angezeigt quasi, oder was?
Chrome zeigt mir halt die Unicode-Zeichen
Schick mir mal die URL, ich möchte mal wissen, wie das in Firefox aussieht.
Wenn ich halt nur rüberkopiere,
ist es halt wirklich diese Zeichen und dann kriegst du den Info-Manager
raus, ich brauche einen Link, der auf das zeigt.
Gut, okay. Dann machen wir es später.
Gut.
Also, let's encrypt.
Kann ich noch was einfügen?
Klar.
Die basteln ja in der Version 2
des ECMI-Protokolls.
Also ECMI-Protokoll ist ja das,
was letztens ein Glück nutzt, um die SSL-Zertifikate
auszustellen,
damit man nachweist,
dass die Domain einem gehört.
Und es wird wohl jetzt an Version 2
des ECMI-Protokolls gearbeitet, welches dann
Whitecard-Zertifikate zulassen
soll. Also sowas wie
stern.kirchen.io
würde dann funktionieren.
Da müssen sie dann auch genau hingucken,
dass nicht Leute stern.com
Ich habe ein SSL-Zertifikat,
das gilt einfach für jede Domain.
Man könnte sich eigentlich schon mal
ein paar lustige Fails zurechtlegen, mal gucken,
was passiert dann. Wo muss das Sternchen
stehen? Ich meine, am Anfang.
Also es gibt da auch wohl Einschränkungen,
je nach Browser ist das unterschiedlich, wie die SSL-Zertifikate
interpretiert werden.
Weil man für manche
Entwicklungs-Szenarien zum Beispiel sowas
haben möchte, wie Sternpunkt, Sternpunkt,
Tab-Level-Domain.
Dass man im Prinzip sagen kann, ich habe
An erster Stelle
meinen speziellen Service,
an zweiter Stelle die Entwicklungsstufe,
Staging, Test. Aber Wildcard-Zertifikate
gibt es ja schon. Aber ich kann jetzt nicht so etwas wie
secure.stern.com
oder.irgendwas.com
haben oder sowas.
Probieren.
Wildcard-Zertifikate gibt es ja schon.
Genau, aber die sind halt nur auf einer Ebene Wildcard.
Das ging halt bei Let's Encrypt noch nicht.
Das heißt... Wildcard hat ja Let's Encrypt
noch nicht ausgestellt.
Es gibt so zwei, drei Sachen,
man eigentlich noch von Netzencrypt haben möchte. Das eine ist auf jeden Fall das mit den Ycard
Zertifikaten. Das kommt jetzt, finde ich sehr toll. Das nächste wäre ein schöner Support für
Eleptic Curve Zertifikate. Also im Prinzip ein neues Kryptosystem mit viel kürzeren Schlüsseln und
die sind auch ungefähr zehnmal so schnell beim Handshake. Also man kann da auch schneller
arbeiten.
Das kann man wohl händisch momentan schon machen,
aber wenn das breit mal unterstützt werden
würde, wäre das auch sehr schön.
Die dritte Sache habe ich gerade vergessen.
Ach ja, andere Key Usages
für diese Zertifikate.
Also ein Zertifikat hat ja immer eine Nutzung
oder einen Nutzungszweck und normalerweise steht
dahinter, es ist
zur Beglaubigung von einem Server
da.
Die können ja bloß Domain-Zertifikate
ausstellen. Genau, Server-Zertifikate.
Und was noch schön wäre, wäre ein Klein-Zertifikate
sodass ich meine E-Mails damit unterschreiben kann
im Let's Encrypt-Zertifikat.
Und wie lasse ich mir so eins dann ausstellen?
Das funktioniert so, indem man den Zertifikatsantrag,
der ja an Let's Encrypt geschickt wird,
nachdem man nachgewiesen hat, wer man ist,
mit einer Nutzungseinschränkung versieht.
Und im Moment, schätze ich, prügelt Let's Encrypt
einfach die Nutzung fest rein.
Also die kopieren im Prinzip...
Also bei einem Domain-Zertifikat weiß ich, dass ich dann halt auf der Domain,
auf dem Server, auf dem das läuft, halt einen Client laufen haben muss,
der diesen Check von Let's Encrypt entgegennimmt,
dass ich quasi auf meiner Domain slash irgendwie so ein Secret ablege.
Das ist ja nur die Beglaubigung.
Genau, aber wenn ich jetzt das nehmen möchte, um meine E-Mails damit zu unterschreiben,
wie beweise ich dann Let's Encrypt, dass ich das bin?
Da muss ich dann...
Theoretisch eine E-Mail würde auch gehen.
dass die im Prinzip nicht sagen,
du musst jetzt an einer bekannten Stelle
auf deinem Sorgen der Datei hinterlegen,
mit einem bestimmten Namen,
den wir dir vorgeben und wir büfen das.
Dann schicken wir eine E-Mail an die Anlässe
und wenn du darauf antwortest, dann bist du das.
Oder wenn du uns einfach den Inhalt,
diesen Key oder die Zufallszeichenfolge dort mitteilst,
dann ist das auch bewiesen.
Das wäre natürlich schön.
Wenn du natürlich den Funktionsumfang von sowas erweiterst,
erweiterst du natürlich auch automatisch
die Angriffsszenarien damit automatisch.
Das ist ein bisschen problematisch.
Ich meine, ich mache sicherlich Gedanken darüber.
Das klingt ja normal.
Ich möchte, also ich
unterstelle dir nichts, aber ich sage,
dass wir wahrscheinlich schon
eine ganze Menge Zeit daran
verwendet haben müssen.
Es sind aber auch schöne Nutzungsvarianten, die man da
bekommt, aber wer weiß, was man da alles so
macht. Es gab ja auch schon mal Angriffe, wo
Angriffe ist Quatsch, aber
Verhinderung von diesen
Cookies, von Browser-Tracking
ist ja immer
eine wichtige Sache, wenn man einmal im Surfen möchte,
möchte man, dass der Browser keine Daten wieder
an den Server übermittelt, über den man identifiziert werden kann.
Und das kann man in der Regel ausschalten.
Und da gab es zum Beispiel auch schon Möglichkeiten, dass man gesagt hat,
für den Verbindungsaufbau fordert der Server an, dass du ein
kleinen Zertifikat mit angibst. Das ist optional.
Und dieses Zertifikat wird im Zweifel einfach
neu ausgestellt im Browser. Und damit hat man dann wunderbar
die Leute tracken können, egal von wo
die herkamen oder egal, ob man Cookies geblasht hat oder nicht.
Egal, ob die noch irgendeine Feierer oder sonst was dazwischen hatten.
Die wurden einfach immer wieder erkannt, weil da quasi ein Client
einen Handshake mit einem Zertifikat gemacht hat,
das ihnen eindeutig identifiziert.
Also diese CEU-Bestimmung, dass Webseiten einem jetzt erzählen müssen,
wenn sie Cookies speichern, ist an und für sich so 1995,
dass es wehtut.
Erstens nervt es jeden und zweitens wird Tracking heutzutage
nicht mehr mit Cookies gemacht.
Wie läuft denn das eigentlich?
Ich meine, da kommt jetzt überall auf blogger.com oder so,
kommt überall dieser Banner, dass die einen Cookie setzen.
Da kann ich auf OK oder wegklicken.
Ich habe es noch nie richtig durchgelesen.
Du klickst auf OK und nimmst das an und du klickst auf Abbrechen
und musst offiziell die Seite verlassen.
Ist das nicht so, ob du da kein Cookie speichern?
Das ist keine wirkliche Zustimmung, die du dir geben kannst.
Du musst bloß darüber ein Kenntnis gesetzt werden.
Du kannst dem nicht widersprechen und dann machen die es nicht.
Ich habe mich die ganze Zeit gefragt, wie machen die dann das?
Die setzen einfach kein Cookie und sobald ich OK klicke,
wird dann per JavaScript das Cookie erst gesetzt.
Und wie tracken die meine Suchanfrage,
wenn ich jetzt auf der Seite doch noch eine Suche absetze.
Die setzen den und
sagen dir bloß Bescheid. Die geben dir nur Bescheid.
Ja. Also wenn ich
jetzt zum Beispiel auf derpostillon.com
gehe. Die haben eine schöne Anlage.
Die hatten
der Postillon verwendet Cookies.
Für alles mögliche.
Werbung, Facebook, NSA.
Durch ihren Besuch stimmen sie dazu zu.
Und die einzige Auswahl, die du hast, ist
mehr Infos dazu oder mir doch egal.
Dann kriegst du halt auf mehr Infos dazu.
Würde mich jetzt doch tatsächlich mal ins wissen.
Mehr Infos sagen, wirst du auf google.com
slash policy slash technology slash
cookies weitergeleitet, Standardseite.
Hier bei.bar-Domains ist mir noch was
eingefallen. Google hat doch eigentlich,
wir haben ja die wunderschöne Seite
akronomisier.bar.
Du hattest maschinen.les.bar.
Ich habe maschinenlesbar.de.
Aber Google hat doch bestimmt
auch google.bar, oder?
Du meinst, ob dieser Begriff google.bar ist?
Da würde ich jetzt erwarten, dass man da
Begriffe eingeben kann. Also google.bar
ist registriert, aber da ist nichts dahinter.
Aber da hätte ich gerne, das funktioniert bloß im
Deutschen, aber da möchte ich dann gerne
auch so eine Google-Suchzeile haben und da
Begriffe eingeben können und da möchte ich ein Score
kriegen, wie googlebar das ist. Und da gibst du
ein Go und dann kriegst du 0.
Und dann gibst du ein Akronomisierbar
und dann kriegst du 100
oder sowas. Es gibt die
Able Top Level Domain. Jetzt kannst du das mit Englisch nach
Googleable draus machen.
Google.able
Gehört aber wohl der Able Incorporated
Firma.
Großartig.
Ich würde ja noch was machen. Ich würde sagen, man
macht dann die Subdomain bin.ich.google.bar.
Da guckt
dann im Prinzip nach, welche Cookies ich mit sende
und sagt mir dann, welche
Suchbegriffe dann auch matchen.
Welchen Schlagworten ich wirklich
sehe? Apropos Google, aber kennt ihr doch dieses
schöne Projekt, das war
Node-Framework. Das war
ein Node-Framework, das konntest du aufsetzen,
eine Webseite zu hosten und
während die Seite lief, hat die
komplette Zeit im Hintergrund versucht,
sich selbst zu googeln. Und in dem Moment, wo er sich selbst gefunden hat,
hat er alles gelöscht.
Die ganze Zeit versucht,
sich selbst zu googeln, den Content, der auf der Seite stand,
den du mit diesem Node-Framework gehostet hast.
Und in dem Moment, wo er was gefunden hat auf Google dazu,
in dem Moment, wo er so indizit war, hat er alles gelöscht.
Dann gab es die Seite nicht mehr. Die war dann down.
Warum?
Einfach nur als witziges Experiment.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es sinnvolle Anwendungsfälle gibt,
aber ich fand es einfach witzig.
Einfach um den Google-Cash zu poisonen.
Cash Poison ist mehr so, ich möchte nicht, dass diese Seite
existiert, soweit Leute sie finden können.
Spannend.
Aber das ist
natürlich auch Heisenbergsche Unschärfe,
wenn das so ist.
Es ist nur wirklich Google-bar,
wenn du anfängst, es auf Google zu suchen,
weil dann Google darauf aufmerksam wird
und das dann anfängt zu suchen und zu indizieren.
Denkst du?
Ich denke, das ist vorher schon drin.
Ich habe die Mail noch gar nicht registriert und Google zeigt schon drauf.
Nee, ich meine,
Ich glaube nicht, dass Google anfängt zu suchen,
ob es irgendwas finden kann,
nur wenn du eine Suche absetzt,
die noch keine Ergebnisse liefert.
Ich denke schon.
Ich denke schon, dass sie zumindest
eine Liste von Sachen haben,
die Leute gegoogelt haben, die nichts gefunden haben,
die keine Treffer produziert hat.
Das ist ja für die ein Problem,
dass die Leute Sachen suchen, die sie nicht finden.
Dann möchten sie entweder herausfinden,
ist das als Lektor daran,
dass der Typ sich vertippt hat,
Und selbst dann könnten wir
hier schauen, dass wir gucken, was sind so typische
Vertipper und die dann die Sachen, die
ja wahrscheinlich eigentlich gemeint hat, anbieten.
Oder ob der Sachen sucht,
die einfach so neu sind, dass wir sie
noch nicht haben, dann sind wir erst recht daran
interessiert, das zu finden. Also ich glaube ich schon,
dass du, sobald du bei Google was eingibst, die
Suchergebnisse für diesen Begriff
in der Zukunft beeinflusst.
Auch allein Sachen, die häufiger gesucht
werden, werden auch in den Schäferlisten wahrscheinlich höher
gerankt. So ein Score,
der dann direkt mit drauf liegt. Das kann nicht sein,
Wenn du einen Begriff suchst bei Google,
ist das ja Information, die du erzeugst.
Ist das Interesse an diesem Begriff?
Google schmeißt ja keine Informationen.
You never lie to your search engine.
Ich habe heute einen schönen
Tech Talk gesehen beim T-Shirts verhalten
heute früh mit
Randall Monroe.
Okay, XKCD-Typ.
Und der hat einen Tech Talk darüber,
überall so ein paar Beispelfragen, die er gekriegt hat
für WhatApp.
Und eine war,
wenn Google seine gesamten Daten
auf Lochkarten speichern würde.
Wie viel umfangreich wäre das dann?
Stark und.
Und der hat dann erstmal die Hälfte der Zeit darüber geredet,
wie schwierig es ist rauszufinden, wie viele Daten
Google vorhält. Dann kam er zum Schluss
dabei raus, dass es wahrscheinlich so 15
Exabyte sind, plus minus 5 Exabyte.
Das ist ein krasser Tolerant.
Dann hat er gesagt, naja, auf so eine
Lochkarte passen
so 160
Byte oder sowas.
Und in so eine Kartonlochkarte
passen so 1000 Lochkarten.
dann hat er quasi eine Übertragung von
Datenmenge auf Volumen und dann hat er gemeint,
wenn wir das jetzt auf die Fläche von New York stapeln würden,
dann, und da hat er so eine schöne Visualisierung gehabt, dann würde
dieser Stapel dreimal so hoch stapeln, wie das Eis bei der letzten Eiszeit.
So ein paar Kilometer hoch. Genau.
Weil er halt bei Google angefragt hatte und sie ihm
keine Antwort geben wollten, auf wie viel Daten sie
vorhalten.
Was er da erwähnt hat, hat er dann, nachdem er das
auf What If geschrieben hat, ein paar Wochen später
dann von Google einen Brief bekommen
und da waren Lochkarten drin.
Da stehen die Informationen
gecodet oder was?
Da hat er dann
angefangen, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen. Wie lese ich das jetzt?
Dann hat er das gelesen, dann ist er nicht genau
darauf eingegangen, hat gesagt, das war dann irgendwie noch
encoded. Dann habe ich mich
mit dem Kuppel zusammen herangesetzt, herauszufinden,
was da...
Humor. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Und dann hat er halt quasi diesen Code gecrackt.
Ich will gar nicht mehr wissen, was so ein Code gewesen sein soll.
Und das Ergebnis, was dann zum Schluss
rauskam, war die offizielle Antwort von Google
auf seine Anfrage und da stand dann, no comment.
Stark.
Oh ja.
Ich habe schon gedacht, es hat ein paar Wachen gedauert, weil die das
DF-H so lange dauern.
Oder DU.
Ich möchte fast behaupten,
dass Google auch bloß so, wie man daumen
weiß, wie viele Daten die wirklich haben.
Die Metrik kannst du nicht einsetzen.
Er meint, die haben irgendwie
den Umsatz von einer, also die haben
einen Festplattenausfall von einer
Festplatte pro Minute oder sowas.
Das ist ziemlich wenig.
Und dann hat er irgendwie versucht,
die Metrix zu nehmen, wie viel
der Festplattenproduktion Google so verbraucht.
Das ist aber auch ein signifikanter Anteil.
Die kaufen ja auch nur so B-Ware-Platten.
Die meine ich mal gelesen zu haben.
Teils, teils.
Die kaufen B-Ware,
weil sie entsprechend viel Redundanz einplanen.
Oder sie kriegen absolut neue
Vorsalmodelle, wenn sie
mit Hitachi oder sonst wer...
Hängen die bei Google in Schwerk und dann testest du mal, wie die laufen.
10 Terabyte Platten oder sowas, die mit
Heliumfüllung rausbringen, dann kriegen die zuerst diese großen...
Ich meine, es gibt keinen besseren Test für deine Platten,
als wenn du die bei Google mal in Schwerk heranhängst und mal schaust,
wie lange die tatsächlich laufen.
Ich habe immer so schöne Dokus mit der Führung durch die Google Headquarters
und da haben dann entweder so
modulare Rechenzentren,
wo quasi
Container ist und in dem Container gehst du rein,
da stehen links und rechts irgendwelche alten Rechner drin,
die sie dann, wenn dann halt was ausfällt,
dann tauschen sie den Gesamt-Container aus.
Und, ja,
das ist so ein paar Jahre her angeblich gehabt,
Google mal Rechenzentren mit alten
PCs betrieben.
Aber die Modularität von so einem Rechenzentrum
bei denen ist auch, dass die halt Racks
in Containern haben und wenn da irgendwas ist,
dann tauschen die halt ganze Container aus.
Die sind irgendwie freischwebend, dass du die Container
von außen kühlen kannst oder so, das ist keine Ahnung.
Das ist so krass, das geht.
aber dann haben die halt, wenn die
Plattenausfall haben, dann nehmen die halt so eine Platte auch
und dann wird die in so eine
Stanze reingetan, wo dann so ein großer Metalldorn
von oben durch die Festplatte durchsticht,
um die Daten wirklich zu zerstören, die da eventuell
immer drauf gewesen sind.
Man muss dir ja einfach lassen,
das Ding ja nicht einfach. Aber das mit den Containern
habe ich auch gehört, das sieht ja im Prinzip aus wie
ein Containerhafen dort. Genau.
Alle hingestellt,
große Kühl-Affikate noch mit dabei
und keine Ahnung, dann hast du dann irgendwie so
ein dickes Ablinkkabel an jedem Container.
Wo wir gerade bei Rechenzentren sind.
Du wolltest noch was von Soundcloud erzählen.
Hat jetzt nichts mit Rechenzentren zu tun.
Die Firma geht gerade so ein bisschen Bach runter.
Die haben irgendwie ihre Heilüberlegschaft komplett gefeuert.
Gut, dass wir immer noch unseren Podcast bei den Hosten.
Ich habe ein bisschen Angst um unsere Daten.
Archive, dann Urkack.
Eigentlich, dass wir unsere Podcast-Folgen verteilt
auf ganz vielen mobilen Endgeräten.
Dann speichern.
Demnächst auch für unsere Hörerschaft.
Habt ihr unsere Folge 2 noch?
Brauchen die bitte für uns?
Nee.
archive.org
archiviert schon
aktiv jeglichen Soundcloud-Inhalt
Also ich kenne
Podcasts, die direkt auf archive.org veröffentlichen
Interessant
Das könnten wir vielleicht auch mal angucken
Wir müssen echt mal uns hinsetzen, unsere Seite
bauen, unsere Podcast-Infrastruktur
im Sinne von, wir wollen die Dinger
selbst hosten und da bestenfalls
über die Mikrowelle OS
das ganze statisch die Seite generieren
Vielleicht können wir das, wenn wir im zweistelligen Bereich ankommen
Wir sind schon längst im zweistelligen Bereich.
Mit welcher Basis?
Du meinst du im Hörerteil?
Nein, ich meine Episoden.
Ach so.
Vielleicht kann mich ja Hendrik heute noch mal motivieren,
mir das Mikrofon jetzt nochmal anzuschauen.
Naja, wir können ja nachher noch mal Bier trinken gehen,
vielleicht steht es hinterher. Mal schauen.
Also es ist mal eine Versprechung.
Es wird zum Veröffentlichen dieser Folge,
die wird auf jeden Fall auf Soundcloud erfolgenlicht,
wird wahrscheinlich eher nicht soweit sein,
aber schauen wir mal.
Nachdem das Schlammer ist.
Das ist ja eher so ein One-in-Gag mit
wir machen unsere eigene Webseite.
Das haben wir schon vor fünf Folgen mal versprochen
und dann rausgeschnitten.
Stimmt, oh Gott.
Ja, es kommt irgendwann mal.
Was ist denn jetzt mal bei SoundCloud passiert?
Ja, wie gesagt, halbe Leegschaft gefeuert.
Die haben kein Geld mehr.
Es reicht wohl nur noch bis zum nächsten Quartal.
Der CEO verspricht offen,
dass die Seite nirgendwo hingeht und das alles passt.
Aber niemand weiß es.
Merkel hat bereits ihr vollstes Vertrauen ausgesprochen.
Das ist traurig.
Das war doch auch so ein cooles deutsches Startup.
Ja, das fand ich auch.
Aber ich habe schon vieles gehört von Leuten,
die bei Suncut gearbeitet haben,
dass die unglaublich toxisch intern waren,
ähnlich wie Uber,
und da nicht gearbeitet haben.
Andere Berichten, genau das Gegenteil.
Es ist schwer zu sagen.
Das wird sich natürlich immer von außen nicht beurteilen.
Ich habe noch vor drei Jahren gehört,
in der Freakshow habe ich das gehört,
dass die damals nur einen ganz großen MySQL-Server hatten
und dass der regelmäßig abends langsam wurde
und dann auf Suncut keine Musik mehr anhören konnte.
Aber ich fand,
das User-Interface,
also diese Technik,
die mit dem Durchscrollen und so.
Kommentare so an die Waveform hängen. Ja, das war
absolut neudermals und richtig schick.
Der Webplayer ist auch immer noch nice.
Und die Plattform? Für Musik
ist das bescheuert, weil
du hast da einen 3-Minuten-Track und das
läuft halt immer über mit Kommentaren, die
irgendwo stehen und das ist alles keine signifikante
Stelle, wo du kommentierst, kannst du nicht einfach sagen,
oh, guck mal, hier geht das geile Solo los.
Aber es klappt halt, wenn du es nicht übertreibst. Also
für Dinge, die nicht ultra-populär werden, dann klappt der Webplayer auch.
Aber bei uns ist das ganz gut,
weil du siehst halt die Chapter-Marks
glaube ich, da dran. Die werden von
die Chapter Marks, Kommentare von unserem
Account selber an unsere Folgen direkt mit dran. So werden die Chapter Marks
in Soundcloud gesetzt. Das ist ja komisch, aber okay.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nett. Auf die Art
und Weise kann man auf
Chapter direkt kommentieren. Ja, aber es wäre halt schöner,
wenn die Chapter Marks von Soundcloud unterstützt
würden und da quasi ein Strich mit dem Titel
ist und nicht das so hacky mit dem Kommentar.
Was cool wäre,
aber auch super scheiße wäre,
wäre so eine Art Soundcloud
pur für Podcaster.
Wäre insofern cool, dass du da
wie ein praktisches User-Interface
mit Syndication und mit Kommentaren
und mit, was weiß ich, anbieten könntest,
dass es wirklich eine schicke
Podcast-Experience wäre. Auf der anderen Seite wäre es
halt ein zentraler Server oder ein zentraler Dienst.
Wäre natürlich cool, wenn du so ein Feature
hast. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie sieht denn das mit diesen
Podcast-Webplayern aus? Ich schaue mir die zu selten an.
Das Ding, was normalerweise
Menschen in die Mikrowelle-Leute direkt mal
eingebaut haben auf ihrer Seite, ist auch unglaublich schick
und läuft ziemlich gut. Und die haben auch
direkt eine Formatauswahl.
Ich glaube, du kannst das
Auphonic-Teil sogar mit nutzen, wenn du
möchtest. Da kannst du direkt die Transcripts sogar
mit einblenden und das funktioniert auch super.
Da hast du Striche mit Chapter Marks.
Ist ja nicht ganz so schick, aber es gibt
viele Möglichkeiten.
Viele Möglichkeiten.
Wollen wir uns damit
rappen? Ich würde schon sagen,
für heute. Also, wo wir nämlich gerade
eh Meta über unseren Podcast
reden, kommen wir doch mal zur Hausmeisterei.
Also, das war Folge 008 von Akronomisierbar.
Vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit.
Vielen Dank für euer Feedback und eure Themenvorschläge auch.
Und vielen Dank, dass ihr...
Mehr davon.
Bitte mehr davon.
Wenn ihr ein cooles Thema habt und in der Gegend von Dresden wohnt,
kommt doch mal vorbei und quatscht mit uns.
Ja, schreibt doch mal an.
Ansonsten sind wir auch sehr präsent.
Sprecht uns einfach mal direkt an oder über Twitter auf
at akronomisierbar oder unsere persönlichen Handels
at hoodie-de.
das bin ich. Ich bin Kilian
K.O.E., ein L bitte.
Ich habe ein witziges, kleiner Eimer
von der Stelle. Ich habe mir letztens den Twitter-Account
Kilian K.O.E. mit zwei L registriert,
wo einfach nur ein Tweet war von wegen
du bist hier falsch und dann liegt zu mir,
Twitter hat den Account suspended, weil ich das nicht witzig fand.
Oh.
Und
Ich bin Ed Steiger.
Mit einem T.
Genau.
Also das war...
Mit einem E.
Bevor wir es jetzt noch unendlich in die Länge ziehen.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr soweit zugehört habt.
Das war auf Akronomisierbar Folge 008.
Und der nächste Podcast in eurem Feed beginnt in 3, 2, 1.
Piep.